So Leute, ich bin am Start, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als ich am Donnerstag online war abends,
hab ich gesagt, Leute, ich streame am Freitag, wisst ihr das noch, und wisst ihr was ich gemacht hab,
ich hab nicht am Freitag gestreamt und nicht am Samstag gestreamt, wo wir wieder mal dabei sind,
wie sehr man sich auf Sachen, die ich sage, verlassen kann, also gar nicht, ich kann
übrigens das Wattpadding mal wegmachen, Vorschau geht nicht, was ist denn da schon wieder los,
Twitch, please, come on brah, warum geht die Vorschau nicht, ah jetzt, man muss bloß was sagen,
da funktioniert es gleich, erste Comment Message, die ich gesehen hab, ist von Stripes107,
das passt doch, so wieder, cute chat am Start, die Deutsche waren das Streamen sozusagen,
wobei ich die Puff aller Wände noch nicht drauf hab, ich hab diesmal tatsächlich auch ein bisschen
geguckt, ich wollte zwar nicht, weil mir diese Sub-Only-Geschichte auf den Sack in ein paar
Sachen hab ich trotzdem geguckt, deine CES Highlights, ich hab noch null geguckt,
noch gar nix geguckt, hast du irgendein Highlight-Video, ich hab noch gar nix geguckt,
ich hab auch alles ignoriert bisher, was ich gesehen hab an Videos dazu, weil ich mir gedacht hab,
ok bevor ich da irgendwie 20 Videos gucke, suche ich mir mal ne ordentliche Zusammenfassung,
ich hab noch gar nix, noch gar nix, was, PS5, ah gut, da hat die PC Gelder was zugeschrieben,
seh ich grade, PS5, Xbox Series X, warum, Microsoft, warum habt ihr das so, warum benennt ihr das in
so was Dummes um, ich hab schon 25 Billiarden mal gesagt, Xbox Scarlett war der perfekte Name
für dieses Ding, ja, aber nee, Xbox Series X, wieder was, wo kein Mensch was mit anfangen kann,
Xbox Scarlett, das wärs gewesen, so ein nicer Name, ja, aber jetzt heißt es Xbox Series X,
das ist so fail, Microsoft, was ist denn los mit euch, Microsoft ist einfach schlauer als wir,
ja, das ist so, die wissen halt, was die Leute haben wollen, ich mein, wer möchte nicht eine
Xbox Scarlett haben, wenn er eine Xbox Series X haben kann, anscheinend sollen ja mehrere
Modelle von der neuen Xbox erscheinen, nee, das wär jetzt ja auch nicht mit Xbox Scarlett,
nee, auch der Name macht damit keinen Unterschied, er hat ein geiles Mirrors Edge Video, okay,
ja schick mal, mal gucken was, was schreiben sie denn hier, Next-Gen-Konsole, also Next-Gen-Konsole,
obgleich wir dem Namen nach einem PC-Magazin sind, naja gut, den Klicks würde ich mir auch
nicht entgehen lassen an denen ihrer Stelle, wird Zeit da schon ein Video dazu machen, okay,
Next-Gen-Konsole, das wissen wir schon, das kennen wir schon, was mich interessiert ist,
wie die PS4 ausschaut, also okay, mal gucken, ob es neue Details gibt, was wir noch nicht wissen
beziehungsweise noch nicht erahnt haben irgendwie, also, 3D-Audio-Sound, was auch immer das sein soll,
3D-Audio-Sound, ich mein, hab ich PS4 gesagt, PS5, was auch immer, die Benamung macht es auch
nicht besser, zumindest ist Sony konsistent, den haben wir hier, den Cotton Quarry Twitch Prime,
dankeschön, huge, dankeschön, aber 3D-Audio-Sound, ich mein, um auch ohne Surround-Anlage einen
Raumklang wahrzunehmen, also richtigen Raumklang geht nur mit Surround-Anlage, das ist mit,
das ist mit Lautsprechern, also das ist quasi mit den Lautsprechern einen Zentimeter vom Ohr weg
gar nicht, geht gar nicht, was geht ist, das was man schon seit Jahren macht, ist halt diese
simulierte Geschichte, also Laufzeiten zwischen dem linken und dem rechten Ohr simulieren,
das machen die Games ja schon lange, und da gibt es ja auch verschiedene, im Prinzip ist das
eigentlich, ist das überhaupt nichts Neues, aber gut, wenn Sony, 3D-Audio, wird spekuliert,
dass Ray Tracing dafür genutzt, genau, Ray Tracing für Audio, das wäre mal hier,
auf Sony würde ich das alles zutrauen, die können ja auch gut, ich mein, die können auch
Schallwellen tracen, das ist dann kein Ray, das ist dann ein Wave Tracing, ist das dann,
nicht Wave Racing, Wave Tracing wäre das dann, einen neuen Controller, Ray Tracing Features,
ein UHD-Laufwerk, so wie eine sehr schnell, SSD, ich sag's ja schon lange,
SSD wird einfach mal echt Zeit, in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass man schon die 360 mit einer
SSD modden konnte, wird's ja mal für die übernächste Konsolengeneration, mal Zeit,
ja, weil ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ging das, you can use it, also man konnte schon eine 360
modden mit einer SSD, aber jetzt kommen sie, jetzt sind sie offiziell auf die Idee gekommen,
ich hätte mir das eigentlich schon für letzte Konsolengeneration gewünscht, dass da eine
SSD drin ist, man hätte es ja ohne Probleme so machen können, dass man für größere Sachen
da schon noch eine Platte reinmacht, weil ich mein, damals war es preislich noch nicht so
ohne weiteres möglich, da eine 512 Plus G SSD reinzumachen, ich mein, heute, heute würde ich
mir da eine 2TB SSD reinmachen, ja, aber das war damals noch nicht so drinne bei der PS4
und bei der Xbox, ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie die letzte hieß, One, und man hätte aber
irgendeinen Kompromiss machen können, also ich hab mir das ehrlich gesagt schon gewünscht,
dass es zumindest eine Upgrade-Option gibt, dass man offiziell eine SSD reinmachen konnte.
Arkenas, ich denke mal, die werden da wieder ein bisschen drauflegen, also es ist ja, es
ist ja, außer bei Nintendo, wobei bei der Switch, weiß ich es gar nicht, keine Ahnung,
wie es da ist, aber es ist ja immer so, dass die Konsolenhersteller erstmal drauf, oder
meistens zumindest drauflegen, wenn die Konsole rauskommt rein bei der Hardware, was dann
irgendwann durch Spieleverkäufe wieder wettgemacht wird, bei der Wii war es nicht so, bei der
Wii U, ich glaube, das fällt überhaupt nicht ins Gewicht, das Ding hat eh keiner gekauft,
und bei der Switch weiß ich es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, ob Nintendo an dem rein verkauften
Switch was verdient, bei der Wii haben sie was verdient, bei der Switch weiß ich es nicht,
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich nicht, ich habe auch keine Ahnung, okay, keine weiteren
Details, okay, der bekannten Features, gucken wir gleich nochmal an, bla, bla, bla, bla,
bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla,
Das Ding ist ja auch eine PS5.
Gut.
Nice. Sony kann zählen im Vergleich zum Microsoft immerhin.
Sony kündigt allerdings an in der Zukunft noch weitere einzigartige Features der Play.
Ich finde das immer toll.
So nach dem Motto,
Leute, heute gibt es eine einzigartige Ankündigung.
Wir werden in Zukunft einzigartige Ankündigungen machen.
Aha.
Ich weiß, man sollte einfach mal sagen, was Sache ist.
Wann genau das sein wird, ist doch unklar.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wissen sie es selber noch nicht genau.
Habt ihr nicht auch das Gefühl, diesmal ein bisschen im Vergleich zur letzten Generation,
dass sich Sony...
Letzte Generation hatte ich das Gefühl, dass sich Microsoft ein bisschen verzettelt hat, ja?
Und dass Microsoft ein bisschen nachziehen musste,
nachdem Sony da mit der PS4 vorneweg geprescht ist.
Diese Generation habe ich so von den News und allem so ein bisschen den Eindruck,
es ist umgedreht.
Microsoft hat schon ziemlich viel fertig.
Microsoft hat ziemlich einen Plan, wie das Ganze aussehen soll.
Microsoft ist auch nicht so extrem restriktiv.
Die erzählen öfters mal was Neues und sagen, so sieht es halt aus.
Und Sony macht ultra Geheimnistaktik.
So nach dem Motto, wir haben die geilste Konsole ever.
Aber wir sagen euch nichts dazu.
Wieso habe ich irgendwie das Gefühl, es ist umgedreht?
Aber, ähm, die PS5 wird sich definitiv gut verkaufen.
Deutschland, also Europa,
also vor allem Deutschland ist ein Playstation-Land.
Hier war die Xbox noch nie so wirklich richtig beliebt.
Also, etwa gleich zur Playstation.
Und die PS5 wird sich allein wegen dem Namen hier gut verkaufen.
Was?
Playstation 5 ist ein Elektroauto?
Nee, ich habe jetzt irgendeinen Zwischensatz übersehen.
Aviciiion S ist ein Elektroauto.
Ich habe jetzt gerade irgendwie gelesen, die PS5 hat ein Elektroauto.
Was hat die PS5 mit Elektroautos zu tun?
Also auf sein wollte ich das nächste Jahr vielleicht viel Neues mal anzeigen.
Guck mal, die zeigen schon was drauf ist.
Durch die Hardware sollen bis zu 120 FPS in UHD möglich sein.
Die Hardware soll bis zu 120 FPS in UHD möglich sein.
Die Hardware und die FPS, ich weiß gar nicht warum die Leute das immer so in Verbindung bringen.
Es gibt ja zwei grundsätzliche Sachen.
Einmal, was kann der reine Ausgang, also was wird da unterstützt?
Also was kann theoretisch über die Schnittstelle raus, also was wird da unterstützt?
Displayport, HDMI, welche Version, sonst was.
Und dann, wenn das, keine Ahnung, 500 Hz, 16K oder was auch immer unterstützt, gibt es nicht.
Dann ist die Hardware zweitrangig, weil ich kann ohne Probleme ein Standbild anzeigen mit 500 FPS, 16K.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Die Frage, die eigentlich viel interessanter ist, die sich dann stellt ist,
was ist in Spielen möglich?
Und ich wette mit euch, so gut wie kein Spiel wird mit 120 FPS in 4K laufen.
Never! Es gibt ja kaum Spiele, die auf einem Highend PC mit 120 FPS in 4K laufen.
Da kannst du Tetris, Tetris, Rick, da kannst du spielen.
Wenn das, ja genau, das ist im Prinzip so wie es hier steht.
Wie gesagt, ich kann da Castle Crashers, Castle Crashers kann ich spielen in 120.
Denn ihr, ihr verwendet alle falsch, ein gerendertes Bild.
Leaked.
Okay, also was haben sie sonst noch gemacht?
AMD, Grafikkarten und CPUs.
Okay, da wird es wahrscheinlich nicht allzu viel tun, denke ich mal.
Übrigens, Hardware, wisst ihr was ich letztens cooles gesehen habe?
Es gibt jetzt einen USB 2.5 Gigabit Ethernet und einen USB 5 Gigabit Ethernet Adapter.
Hab ich letztens Tests dazu gesehen, das ist eine richtig, ist auch gar nicht so teuer, ne?
Das ist eine richtig schicke Alternative, nicht den da, irgendein anderer.
Das ist eine richtig schicke Alternative zu Leuten, die kein PC express mal frei haben
oder auch sich keine 10 Gigabit SFP Plus Karte oder sowas kaufen wollen.
Das ist ziemlich viel, ist nicht ganz so schnell und die meisten 10 Gigabit Switches können das.
Weil ich das, das finde ich ganz cool, dass es es mittlerweile gibt als USB.
Ja und für ein bisschen sequentielle Daten in und her schieben auf und nass,
ist es scheißegal, ob das jetzt ein PCIe Express Nightware Karte ist oder ob das jetzt ein USB Ding ist.
Die neuesten Gerüchte über die nächsten AMD Karten sagen ja, wird bis zu 30% schneller als eine 2080 Ti.
Wenn das stimmt und die Konsole, ja hoffentlich, hoffentlich.
Also es wäre ja schon mal wünschenswert, wenn AMD überhaupt eine Grafikkarte hätte,
die so schnell ist oder zumindest mithalten könnte mit den Highend Modellen von Nvidia.
Bisschen laut die Musik, oder?
Ähm...
Es wäre ja schon mal schön, wenn AMD überhaupt was hätte, was mithalten könnte bei Nvidia Highend technisch.
Das heißt, ich wäre ja schon zufrieden, wenn AMDs nächste Highend Grafikkarte genauso schnell ist,
wie Nvidias nächste Highend Grafikkarte.
Weil ich meine, wann kam die 2080 Ti raus? Das ist jetzt ja auch schon ein bisschen her.
Ähm...
Wo kam das Ding raus? Hier.
Vor, vor...
einem Jahr?
Vor ungefähr einem Jahr, eineinhalb Jahren oder so?
Hier, September.
Sind wir mal großzügig sagen, eineinhalb Jahre?
Nicht ganz. Aber sagen wir einfach mal eineinhalb Jahre.
Das heißt, wann auch immer, es wird ja nicht mehr so ewig dauern.
Also da vergehen jetzt ja keine drei Jahre mehr oder so,
bis die nächste Grafikkarten-Generation irgendwann mal rauskommen muss.
Und ich wäre ja schon froh, wenn es AMD schaffen würde, eine Grafikkarte rauszubringen,
ungefähr in dem gleichen Zeitraum, die ungefähr genauso schnell ist,
wie die dann kommende Highend Grafikkarte von Nvidia.
Das wäre ja schon mal was.
Ich glaube, wir können uns freuen, wenn es AMD schafft,
diese Generation gleich zu ziehen mit Nvidia.
Ich fände es auf jeden Fall gut, muss ich euch ehrlich sagen.
Man hat ja gesehen bei CPUs, was das Ganze bewirkt hat.
Wir sind dank AMD von Highend 4-6 Kerne zu Desktop Highend zu 16 Kernen.
Innerhalb von zwei Jahren.
Das haben wir nur AMD zu verdanken, nicht Intel oder so,
dass die gesagt haben, wir sind jetzt so der Gönner.
Nee, das haben wir nur AMD zu verlangen,
dass wir von 6 auf 16 Kerne hoch sind im Desktop-Bereich.
Und ich hoffe ja mal, dass wenn AMD zumindest wieder halbwegs konkurrenzfähig ist,
wir reden ja noch gar nicht mal von übertreffen,
halbwegs konkurrenzfähig ist zu Nvidia-Grafikkarten,
dass sich da vielleicht auch ein bisschen was tut.
Wem gehört AMD eigentlich gerade?
Wem gehört eigentlich AMD gerade?
Ich blick da nämlich die Dienste.
Siehst du auch mal, irgendwelchen Saudis gehört.
Hat das mal zwischenzeitlich gehört.
Dann weiß ich keine Ahnung mehr, wer das jetzt gehört.
Zu wem gehören die dann?
Ich blick da nicht mal durch.
Das wird zu viel Business.
AMD ist gute Preis-Leiste oder irre ich mich.
Über irgendwas müssen sie die Sachen ja verkaufen.
Also mit CPUs auf jeden Fall.
Also CPU-technisch hat Intel gerade wenig zu lachen.
Das einzige Segment, wo Intel noch irgendwie ihre Sachen an den Mann bringen kann,
wenn man objektiv ist,
ist ein wirklich rein auf Gaming bezogener Rechner.
Ich würde sogar sagen inklusive Übertaktung.
Und dann auch nur, wenn man die richtigen Games anguckt,
dann ist Intel noch ein bisschen schneller.
Ein bisschen, aber auch nicht so viel schneller,
dass ich sagen würde, es rechtfertigt sich,
ein neues Intel-System hinzustellen.
Unterm Strich kann es natürlich jeder machen, wie er will.
Aber an sich gibt es meiner Ansicht nach aktuell
nicht so viele Sachen, die für eine Intel-CPU sprechen,
wenn man sich neuen Rechner zusammenbaut.
Weder Preis-Leistung noch Leistung.
Also wer wirklich Leistung haben will,
da macht sich da ein 3950x hin,
wer so eine Kombination braucht aus Spiele-Rechner,
Render-Rechner, Universal-Power-Ding,
und wer was kleineres braucht,
ein 3700x oder sowas.
Und natürlich, man kann auch einen Intel nehmen.
Aber wer hätte es denn gedacht vor zwei Jahren,
dass Intel mal derjenige ist, der seine CPUs billiger machen muss,
und teilweise um 40% oder so billiger machen muss,
dass sie noch gekauft werden?
Das hätten wir vor zwei Jahren wirklich nicht gedacht.
Ach, das Ding habe ich gesehen, ja.
Das habe ich gesehen, da habe ich irgendwo
so eine Artikel zugelesen.
Das ist von Ali, also von Dell.
Dieses Ding, was erstaunlich an die Switch erinnert.
Aber der Unterschied ist zur Switch,
und deswegen bin ich auch der Meinung,
es wird kompletter Griff ins Klo.
Es ist ein Windows-Rechner.
Was an sich nicht schlecht sein muss,
ein Windows-Rechner hat einen großen Vorteil gegenüber einer Switch.
Es läuft halt einfach ohne Anpassung was drauf.
Es ist halt einfach, es geht halt einfach.
Allerdings bin ich mir sehr unschlüssig.
Ja, was hat das Ding für Specs? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Das ist eine gute Frage, was da für Specs drinstecken.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da allzu OP-Sachen drin sein werden.
Ah nee, bei Golem hatte ich es gelesen, genau.
Was ist denn da drin? Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das da steht.
Okay, also, wenn ich mir das Ding so angucke,
also auch wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie kompakt das ist.
Es war nicht so kompakt wie eine Switch.
Es hat eine höhere Auflösung, wie kompakt das ist.
So die ultra-high-end-Hardware kann da gar nicht drin sein.
Das wird da viel zu warm.
Das eigentliche Problem, wovon ich ausgehe,
warum das ganze Griff ins Klo sein wird,
ist, weil das halt irgendwie so eine Nischenlösung ist.
Die Leute, die PC spielen wollen,
die haben eine Desktop-PC und spielen das auf einem Desktop-PC.
Und die Leute, die mobil spielen wollen,
ich frage mich auch, wie sie das mit den Akkus machen wollen bei dem Zeug.
Da muss ja im Prinzip irgendwie
irgendeine Mobile-Abkömmling-Geschichte drin sein.
Sonst hast du da halt irgendwie eine halbe Stunde Akkulaufzeit oder so.
Leute, die mobil spielen wollen,
die haben wahrscheinlich schon sowas wie eine Switch oder ein 3DS,
vielleicht noch, wenn sie ein bisschen was älteres haben.
Oder keine Ahnung.
Aber ich sehe nicht so wirklich den Anwendungszweck für sowas.
Und das große Problem dabei wird sein,
wenn du dir ein Switch-Spiel kaufst,
Heinoop, Stufe 1, danke schön, 4 Monate.
Wenn du dir einen Switch kaufst, dann weißt du,
das wird halt funktionieren.
Das wird auf jeden Fall funktionieren,
ohne größeres Rumgebasteln.
Und hiermit holst du dir halt wieder die gleichen Nach- und Vorteile von einem PC ins Haus.
Nur, dass du halt wahrscheinlich im Vorfeld schlecht abschätzen kannst,
wie gut das Ganze laufen wird.
Hier siehst du Steam drauf.
Ja, hier sehen wir Steam drauf.
Was heißt im Endeffekt,
in Steam wird es wahrscheinlich keine Kennzeichnung geben.
So nach dem Motto, ähm...
Getestet für Alien-UFO.
Bestimmt nicht.
Das gibt es, das wird es in Steam nicht geben.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, du kaufst dir dann, keine Ahnung,
The Witcher 4 oder so, wann auch immer das rauskommt,
keine Ahnung,
und wirst dann halt feststellen,
oh Mist, das läuft mit 20 FPS.
Zumal ich halt auch Bedenken habe,
dass so eine Nischenlösung irgendwie nennenswerte Updates bekommt.
Ich meine, es bekommt die normalen Winners Updates,
aber wie es um Hardwarefehler oder Treiber und sonst was angeht,
ich glaube, das ist ein interessantes Konzept,
aber ich glaube, das wird im Ansatz schon failen.
Oh Michael, 50 Billionen.
Also ich glaube, das wird nichts.
Von der Idee her finde ich es ganz gut,
aber mal gucken, ob das Ding überhaupt jemals erscheint.
Ein Spiel wie Formel 1 2019 packt das richtig.
Ich weiß nicht, wie anspruchsvoll das ist,
aber wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr.
Die SSDs.
Ja, das habe ich schon immer gebraucht im Desktop-Bereich.
Die SSD mit 6,5 GB lesen und 5 GB schreiben.
WTF.
Das sind 50 GB in 10 Sekunden.
Das sind 300 GB in einer Minute.
Äh, stimmt.
Quickmaps.
Was?
Also das ist natürlich ordentlich,
aber ob man das jetzt wirklich braucht?
Ich weiß nicht.
Eher weniger.
Joe ist auch mal wieder am Start.
Wie, das war es jetzt schon?
Jetzt haben sie mich hier, seht ihr das?
Sie debaten einen hier auf die nächste Seite
und dann gibt es gar nichts mehr.
Das ist richtig hier.
Huge Debate.
Okay, genau, da wollten wir noch mal kurz reingucken,
ob es da jetzt irgendwie was interessantes Neues zu PS5 gegeben hat.
Aber so wie ich Sony kenne, eher nicht.
Und deswegen, ich habe das Gefühl,
diesmal rudert Sony ganz schön mit den Händen rum,
während Microsoft relativ klar ist, was sie macht
und auch öfters was zeigen können.
Hast du den 64 Quadratmeter?
Nein.
Wir gehen davon aus, dass alles, was auf der PS4 läuft,
auf der PS5, ja 100 pro.
Also wenn Sony das verkackt, dann lache ich sie echt aus.
Also wenn die die Rückwärtskompatibilität
zur PS4 verkacken, dann ist das Unfähigkeit kaum zu überbieten.
Ich meine, da ist kein großer Unterschied mehr.
Es ist ja nicht mehr, dass es wie bei der PS3 gewesen wäre.
Hast du da ein komisches Cell-Gedöns drinne haben?
Die haben jetzt ganz stinknormales X86 drin
und haben dann auch stinknormales X86 drin.
Also wenn das nicht läuft auf der neuen PS5,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Hast du mal den Vortrag von Fail Overflow zu PS4 gesehen?
Nee.
Ja, mache ich, mache ich.
Wir spielen Half Life noch fertig.
Aber ich habe ja letztes Jahr gesagt,
eigentlich wollte ich ja Freidas schon streamen
und Samstags streamen, aber so wie das ist,
ich kann euch mal was zeigen.
Habe ich wieder zu viel rumgebastelt
und ich zeige euch mal, was ich gebastelt habe.
Ich zeige euch mal kurz bevor wir weiter gucken,
was ich gebastelt habe.
Die iPhone, das Ding ist übrigens nicht am Brennen.
Die iPhone-Kamera spackt ein bisschen rum.
Ich weiß nicht, was die iPhone-Kamera da macht.
Eigentlich hat das Ding hier oben bloß eine blaue LED
und da unten eine rote LED.
Warum das ganze Gehäuse jetzt so aussieht,
als würde es brennen, weiß man nicht genau.
Und zwar, ich habe meinen Stromzähler-Auswärter
wieder ein bisschen geupgradet.
Aktuell hängt das Ding ja einfach so im Verteilerkasten,
im Keller rum.
Und ich habe jetzt was Neues gebastelt mit Display,
mit 3D-gedrucktem Gehäuse und eine Vemos-Mini drinnen.
Und da kann ich dann einfach die Sensoren anschließen
im Keller vom Stromzähler-Metgeschoss,
vom Stromzähler im ersten Stock.
Und das Ganze überträgt es dann auch per WLAN
an meine Heimautomatisierung.
Aber ich habe ein Display eingebaut,
dass wenn man davor steht, dass man mal vergleichen kann,
ob das Ganze stimmt.
Also sprich, ob der Zählerstand auf dem Zähler
und das Gerät, was meint, was der Zählerstand ist,
ob das auch stimmt.
Da war ich ein bisschen am Basteln und am 3D-drucken
die letzten zwei Tage, weil es funktioniert.
Nicht weil ich wirklich bräuchte,
die alte Lösung funktioniert auch,
aber weil es geht.
Da habe ich die letzten zwei Tage,
oder letzten Samstag eigentlich nur
dran rum gebastelt.
Max Engineer, genau.
Der ist gut, den könnte man sich im Stream angucken.
Was?
Was könnte man sich im Stream angucken?
Ach, den Vortrag.
Schicke mal, schicke mal einen Link.
Was?
Overfail?
Ne.
Live-Overfail?
Warte mal, wie hieß er?
Fail-Overflow, genau.
Was hat er da?
Ach, auf den da.
Ne, den habe ich mit.
Ne, Moment.
Welchen denn?
Ah, hier.
Wobei, doch.
Der ist ja gar nicht von diesem.
Ich glaube, den kenne ich.
Ich glaube, den kenne ich, den Vortrag.
Aber den können wir uns jetzt nicht.
Guck mal, das geht.
Das geht rein 53 Minuten.
Hacked by Overflow, Playstation 4.
Das können wir uns irgendwann mal angucken, wenn Big Brain Time ist.
Ich speichere mir das mal.
Das gucken wir uns mal an, wenn wir unser Gehirn mal wieder anstrengen müssen.
Wollen.
Ich muss mal kurz schauen, dass ich dem Chat nichts übersehen habe.
So, ist das denn VDE-Geprüft?
Wozu?
Das kommt ja noch nicht mal an die Geräte elektronisch richtig dran.
Das ist alles optisch.
Da hängt ein optischer Sensor an dem oberen Stromzähler und ein optischer Sensor an dem
unteren Zähler.
Da ist ja elektrisch gar nichts verbunden.
Also was gibt es denn sonst noch Interessantes zu PS4?
Also zeige ich mal hier.
Blablabla.
SSD, das wissen wir schon.
Extrem verkürzte Ladezeiten.
Blablabla.
Welche Konsole?
Das erzählen sie jedes Mal.
Das hat genauso viel Aussagekraft, wie wenn ich sage, heute wird der beste Stream aller
Zeiten.
Ich kann viel sagen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Laut ihm.
Ich finde das toll, wie sie sich dann immer da einen abrubbeln drauf, wenn sie eine SSD
einbauen und quasi dann die Ladezeiten haben, wie du es mit dem PC schon die letzten zehn
Jahre hast.
Oh mein Gott, Ladezeiten mit der SSD sind schneller.
Wer hätte davon, wer hätte sich das nur denken können?
Wir sagen dann, PC-Spieler, ist das jetzt was Neues?
True.
Lullwee.
Genau.
GPU verbaut ist Raytracing.
Ja, da muss AMD, das würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn AMD Raytracing technisch noch
ein bisschen nachzieht.
Raytracing ist so eine Sache.
Ich bin mir da noch ein bisschen unschlüssig, was da in Zukunft noch kommen wird.
Es ist auf jeden Fall kein totaler Rohrkrepierer, weil man sieht, dass das Interesse da ist
und dass es auch schon ein paar Umsetzungen gibt.
Aber ob das so das große Ding wird, dass jetzt jeder sagt, wir benutzen Raytracing, da bin
ich mir noch unschlüssig.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, es wird eine nette Sache sein, die man zusätzlich noch einbaut,
um es noch ein bisschen optisch rein, von der Optik her, ein bisschen schöner zu machen
an manchen Stellen.
Aber das zieht halt auch Leistung wie Sau.
Deswegen habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Ja, Failure, haben wir gerade drüber gesprochen, dass ich mir wünschen würde, dass AMD, also
ich glaube nicht, dass AMD die nächste Nvidia-Grafikkarte um 20% übertreffen wird.
Also wenn High-End AMD auf High-End Nvidia trifft in der nächsten Generation, dann wird
wahrscheinlich Nvidia, also dann hoffe ich, dass zumindest AMD gleichziehen kann.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie schneller sein werden.
So, soll deutlich realistischer Lichteffekt laufen, 8K-Support sorgen für ein gestochen
scharfes Bild.
Was für ein...
Na ja, gut.
Kein Spiel, da wird nichts in 8K laufen.
Nix.
Der Ausgang kann vielleicht 8K, das war es aber schon.
Kannst du dir NAS empfehlen, ab circa 10TB?
Nö, mein NAS ist selbstgebaut, ich kann dir leider keins...
Ich habe da keine Erfahrung drin.
Zumindest nicht in Consumer-Geräte.
Alter, übeles Husten.
Also das Bild mit 8K ist auch nicht schärfer als mit 4K oder schärfer als mit 1080p.
Das sind genug Pixel, um ein scharfes Bild auf einem 52 Zoll Display hinzubekommen.
Und wenn was in 8K läuft, dann vielleicht wirklich das Hauptmenü, wenn ich es auf Output
8K stelle.
Na ja.
Selbst 4K mit 60 Bildern pro Sekunde werden wir nicht sehen.
Zumindest nicht oft.
Wenn ältere Spiele portiert werden oder grafisch nicht so anspruchsvolle Spiele, die können
meinetwegen in 4K 60 FPS laufen.
Aber da wird kein Uncharted 5 oder was auch immer dann da kommt, wird niemals da in voller
Pulle in gar 8K oder so laufen.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Also wenn die Hardware das sein wird, was man vermutet, dann ist das ungefähr so anzusiedeln
auf einem aktuellen, nicht absolut High-End PC.
Und welche Spiele laufen schon auf einem mittel bis mittelklasse, ganz gute mittelklasse
Rechner, welche Spiele laufen da, also wirklich grafisch anspruchsvolle Spiele laufen da in
guten Details, 4K 60 FPS.
Nicht so wirklich viele.
Wir gehen eher von einem hochskalierten Bild bei 8K und nativen 4K aus.
Das ist auch totaler Blödsinn.
Mit was das Ding native läuft, das entscheidet das Spiel, in was das rendert.
Das ist nicht so, dass es irgendwie der Fernseher oder die Konsole entscheidet.
Nur weil der Displayausgang 4K oder 8K macht, kann das Spiel intern auch in 640 x 480 rendern.
Das ist doch, aber damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Der Framebuffer ist halt so groß, wie der Framebuffer groß ist und da ist nicht 4K,
weil der Ausgang 4K ist.
Zum Vergleich, die PS4 aber blablabla.
3D Sound schon mal wieder.
Ich meine, das ist PC Games, die sollen eigentlich wissen, wovon sie reden.
Ich meine, okay, es geht um Konsolen.
Dann haben sie wahrscheinlich alles vergessen wieder.
Jetzt ist die Musik wieder zu leise.
Dieser komische Stream kann sich nicht entscheiden.
Hier gilt alle Angaben ohne Gewehr.
Ach, ich dachte, ihr wisst schon.
Ich dachte, ich kann euch jetzt verklagen, wenn das Ganze nicht stimmt.
Okay, also im Prinzip wissen wir, dass wir wenig wissen.
Tja, sehr gut.
Wir wissen, wir sind im Prinzip genauso schlau, wie vorher.
Wir haben im Prinzip genauso wenig Ahnung, wie vorher, oder?
Kein Unterschied, wir hätten uns das jetzt auch sparen können, zu lesen.
Müsste das mit allen Angaben ohne Gewehr nicht vor dem Artikel stehen?
Nee, das ist ein Artikel, wo es ganz klar um Spekulation geht.
Da kann keiner die PC Games, selbst wenn die PC Games schreiben würde,
wir haben ganz furchtbar sichere Informationen, dass die PS5 das und das haben würde.
Sie hat das nicht.
Wegen was willst du die verklagen?
Schadensersatz, traumatische Erlebnisse.
Keine Ahnung, es gibt ja nichts.
Was soll ich mir angucken?
Schau dir mal Origin The Big O.
Klingt an wie ein Porn, Alter.
Was soll das sein?
Okay, ich habe Safe Search an Origin The Big O.
Ah, das ist tatsächlich ein PC.
Das hört sich an wie ein Porn Titel, Alter.
Okay, Ultimate Gaming, was soll ich mir da angucken?
Warum ist da ein Xbox Logo drin?
Warum ist in einem RGB-PC ein Xbox Logo drin?
Warum steht Origin drauf? Das verwirrt mich.
Was, was, es sieht sehr gestylt aus, aber was ist denn drin?
Was, da ist ein Switch drin?
Wait, what?
Zuteufel ist da ein Switch drin.
Ach, das ist ein, jetzt verstehe ich, dass da ist eine Xbox drin, ein Switch drin.
Was, warum?
Weil es geht.
Ja, ist klar, ist klar.
Okay, der Rechner kostet allein schonmal 5000 Euro.
Haben wir nicht sogar schon ein Video, kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Okay, kostet, kostet, kostet, Geld, ich will sehen, was es kostet.
Wo, wo, Special Offers, New Year Sale.
Ich will das haben, ich will jetzt wissen, was es kostet.
Price, buy, wo kann ich es kaufen, wo kann ich es kaufen?
Das ist was anderes, oder?
Okay, was?
Das ist aber was anderes jetzt.
Ach, das war ein Einzelstück, okay, okay.
Ey, das ist allein schon teuer genug.
Naja, okay, muss ich ehrlich sagen, es sieht cool aus.
Sinnhaftigkeit erschließt sich mir nicht so hundertprozentig,
weil warum brauche ich ein Gehäuse, wo alles drin ist,
wenn ich doch ohne Probleme einfach meine zwei Konsolen nebeneinander stellen kann?
Also, weißt du, ich meine, also wozu, warum?
Ich meine, es hat, es sieht nice aus, das ist aber auch alles, ja.
Das dürfte Upgrade-technisch oder generell wartungsmäßig der absolute Alptraum sein, da irgendwas dran zu machen.
Es ist eigentlich zu schade wegzuwerfen nach vier Jahren,
aber dir wird wahrscheinlich nicht so viel anderes übrig bleiben als da,
nächste Konsolengeneration wirst du auch nicht reinmachen können.
Außer cool aussehen und wahrscheinlich Schweine teuer sein,
sehe ich da jetzt nichts unbedingt, was ich haben will.
Was ist denn das? Ist das eine Minimaus?
Sieht aus wie eine Mikromaus. Was soll das sein überhaupt?
Kann man nicht ranzoomen, geht nicht, erlaubt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, wir gucken noch ein paar andere Sachen.
So, irgendwas wollte ich euch ja noch zeigen gerade, hab ich voll vergessen.
Ach ja, wer sich noch dran erinnern kann, wo ich meine Steckdosenleiste im Stream geflasht habe,
es gibt jetzt, nur mal so zur Info, weil mich immer noch Leute nach der Steckdosenleiste fragen,
gibt es jetzt eine neue Version von diesem Konverterskript,
der kann jetzt auch die aktuellen Geräte wiederflaschen.
Bisher war nämlich das Problem, dass die neuen Geräte, die man gekauft hat,
mit diesem komischen China, Tuya Cloud Geschichten drauf,
dass man die mit diesem Skript nicht mehr flaschen konnte,
beziehungsweise nicht mehr konverten konnte zu ohne China Cloud,
und die neue Version kann das wieder.
So, ich muss mal kurz Chat gucken.
So, und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wir gucken jetzt gleich mal was,
das hab ich nämlich gerade auf der YouTube Startseite empfohlen bekommen,
nämlich Windows Fan Tested Linux.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab das noch nie, mir sagt dieser Channel gar nichts, ja,
aber ich bin einfach mal gespannt, was ein Windows Fan auf YouTube dazu sagt.
Yes, Steckdosen flaschen, ja, exellent, was sonst, ich hab mich verklickt.
Natürlich Steckdosen flaschen, warum nicht?
Besser eine Steckdose ohne China Cloud als eine schicke Steckdose mit China Cloud.
Hat Tuya dann Alexa Unterstützung?
Du hast dann das, was du draus machst, also du kannst dann Kanal
und das Motor drauf flaschen oder irgendeine andere Custom-Firmware,
die du steuern kannst über alles Mögliche, ja.
Die ist dann ziemlich standardkonform, die geht dann entweder über MQTT
oder über HTTP-Aufrufe.
Und wenn du irgendeinen Server hast, der deine Alexa-Kommandos
zu MQTT oder HTTP-Aufrufen macht, kannst du damit das auch mit Alexa steuern.
Also ja, gibt's eigentlich kaum Probleme mit.
Aber MQTT ist natürlich das bessere Protokoll in dem Fall.
MQTT.
Bald der Minecraft-Server auf der Steckdose.
Das funktioniert nicht, Java läuft da nicht drauf.
Es soll für Streamer sein, die auf Konsole spielen, da dort eine Capture-Card drin ist.
Gut, eine Capture-Card, die ist handgroß, da brauchen wir nix.
So, ich muss jetzt noch mal kurz schauen, dass ich den Chat nix übersehen hab.
Stimmt noch mal eine Frage.
Cola from scratch.
Hier, das können wir uns auch noch angucken.
Was auch immer.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt mal den Windows-Fan an, der Linux testet.
Da bin ich mal gespannt. Im Prinzip ist es ja das, was ich auch öfters im Stream mache,
um mir neue Linux-Distributionen angucken.
Allerdings, ich bin das genaue Gegenteil.
Ich bin kein Windows-Fan.
Ja, Flo96, da hast du schon nicht unrecht.
Er schreibt, LOL.
Steckdosenleiste flashen wegen Datenschutz und dann eine Alexa rumstehen haben.
Es gibt Leute, die flashen ihre Steckdosenleiste nicht wegen dem Datenschutz.
Es gibt Leute, die flashen.
Also bei mir ist es unter anderem ein Grund, warum ich meine Steckdosenleiste flashe.
Ich hab keinen Bock, dass es den China-Cloud-Zugang braucht.
Aber man kann seine Steckdosenleiste oder andere Geräte auch flashen,
um mehr Funktionen zu bekommen und sie angenehmer benutzen zu können,
als mit der Standard-Firmware.
Weil zum Beispiel die Standard-Firmware, die da drauf ist auf dieser Steckdosenleiste,
die braucht die offizielle Android-App zum, die offizielle Android- und iOS-App,
um es zu bedienen.
Und man hat keine Chance, es irgendwie über standardisierte Schnittstellen zu bedienen.
Was natürlich doof ist, wenn man das beispielsweise in seine Heimautomatisierung
oder sonst was integrieren will.
Es gibt Leute, die wollen Sachen in die Heimautomatisierung integrieren
und trotzdem Alexa verwenden.
Und für die ist das auch sinnvoll.
Okay.
Jetzt schauen wir uns das mal an.
Also was ist dann eigentlich Huawei Linux?
Hab ich noch nie was von gehört.
Huawei Selling Linux, ach, das sind die Typen, die von Google,
nee, nicht von Google, von den USA boykottiert werden, oder?
Ja, das sind die.
Kann man das downloaden?
Ah, Deepin ist installiert, Leute.
Das passt doch.
Da ist Deepin drauf.
Deepin haben wir uns letzten Stream angeguckt.
Also wer wissen will, was ich zu Deepin Linux sage,
der guckt sich einfach den letzten Stream an.
Spricht man eigentlich Huawei aus?
Was?
Ernsthaft?
Huawei?
War das richtig?
Pavilion Man.
Huawei.
Ist das ein Windows Phone?
Das könnte ein Windows Phone sein.
Aber es ist ja Windows Fan.
Wenn wir einen Windows Fan brauchen, Windows Phone.
Scheißegal, ob eingestellte...
Your Way.
Okay, was auch immer.
Ich kann das eh nicht richtig.
War Way?
Was?
Ja, wie jetzt, Leute?
Wie?
Ich prüfe das jetzt aus.
Egal, wir gucken uns jetzt den Windows Fan an, der Deepin Linux testet.
Hi Leute.
Ich bin Sahra von windowsarea.de und das ist Deepin Linux.
Ach, jetzt weiß ich auch, warum wir das empfohlen bekommen.
Das sind doch die, wo wir an Silvester ein Video geguckt haben,
die zehn oder sieben größten Windows Geheimnisse oder sowas.
Okay, wir kriegen jetzt erst mal als Erklärt,
wie man den Hersteller richtig ausspricht.
Okay, War Way würde ich es nicht aussprechen.
Cross Sandwich?
Ich glaube, ich sage kein Mensch, oder?
Also außer Kokona.
War Way?
Okay, das muss ich mir ausschreiben, das vergesse ich sonst.
Moment, hat er jetzt wirklich eine Minute 20 Video gemacht,
um einmal fünf Sekunden das Wort auszusprechen?
War Way?
Okay, also testet er War Way Linux.
Leute, big brain time heute im Stream.
You know the way.
Na, das ist ja schon wieder komplett out.
Das ist genauso out, wie diese YouTube Comments.
Keiner, keiner, wirklich keiner.
Das ist auch nicht mehr angesagt.
Welche YouTube Comments sind jetzt eigentlich gerade wieder im Trend?
Ich kenne mich daher nicht so aus.
Okay, also jetzt erst mal gucken, was sagt denn der Linux Fan?
Hi Leute, ich bin es Albert von Windows Area.de und das ist Deepin Linux.
Also jenes Linux, was War Way auf seinen Laptops statt Windows installieren wird.
Und der geneigte Linux Fan hat jetzt schon das Video abgeschaltet.
Was weiß denn schon dieser Windows Bastard über Open Source Software?
Der Windows Bastard, Alter.
Jetzt wird das aber wissen, ey.
Aber das kann man alles googlen und ich will das Video nicht unnötig in die Länge ziehen.
Es geht ja nicht um mich, sondern um einen Hersteller,
welcher jetzt auf Linux statt auf Windows setzt.
War Way installiert bei seinen Matebooks in Zukunft eine Linux-Distribution.
Ja gut, den bleibt doch nicht, dass der übrig.
Werfen wir in diesem Video einen näheren Blick auf Linux,
welches auch als das schönste Betriebssystem aller Zeiten bezeichnet wird.
Also wir haben uns ja letztes Mal angeguckt, das habe ich auch gesagt.
Also wir haben ja schon einige Linux-Distributionen ausprobiert im Stream.
Und ich muss sagen, rein so vom Look und Feel her, es ist ein Custom Gnome,
es ist ein Custom Gnome 3, aber so rein vom Look und Feel her muss ich sagen,
es hat von allen diesen noob-freundlichen Desktop-Linux-Distributionen optisch,
so wie es zusammenpasst, den besten Eindruck gemacht.
Erstmal eine Runde Sellout.
Das haben wir geguckt im Dezember.
Deswegen kriegen wir das auch empfohlen, das Video.
11 versteckte Windows 10 Tricks.
Da waren tatsächlich eins oder zwei ganz gute Tricks dabei.
Ein Fokus auf Windows 10.
Wenn wir auch in letzter Zeit ein kleines bisschen abschweifen, muss ich zugeben.
Huawei setzt auf seinen Laptops jetzt auf Linux.
Die US-Regierung hat ja im Sommer amerikanischen Firmen den Verkauf von Technologien an Huawei untersagt.
Daher hat Huawei nun keinen Zugriff mehr auf Android mit Google Apps
und auch nicht mehr auf Windows 10.
Deshalb wird der Hersteller ab sofort keine Laptops in China mit Linux ausliefern.
Sollte das Handelsverbot länger...
Ja, nix ist so. Dafür ist sowas gut.
Du kannst noobs nicht vor E3 setzen.
Dürfte das also auch in Europa kommen.
Oh, wow.
Habt ihr das gesehen, Leute?
Der Hersteller ab sofort keine Laptops in China mit Linux ausliefern.
China?
Sollte das Handelsverbot länger bestehen, dürfte das also auch in Europa kommen.
Ja.
Was ist da los?
Hat er mal ein Meme-Tool geklaut?
Ich glaub's ja nicht.
Das war nicht von mir, die Einblendung.
Also schnallt euch an, denn bald benutzen wir alle Linux.
Also, vorerst zumindest, wenn ihr in China wohnt und einen Laptop von Huawei kauft.
Das werden die Matebooks nämlich mit Deepin Linux ausgeliefert.
Wir haben die Distribution installiert und für euch getestet.
Wo liegen die Vorteile?
Welche Nachteile gibt es?
Und kann man mit Linux eine Windows-Installation ersetzen?
Gleich mal verwenden.
Kommt dran, was man machen will.
Im Jahr 2019 geht das besser als je zuvor.
Während man noch vor ein paar Jahren...
Solang man nicht spielen will...
Und solang man nicht Photoshop verwenden will oder Affinity oder Vegas oder Premiere...
Ich kann eine ganze Weile weitermachen oder irgendwelche Steuersoftware oder so.
Also irgendwelche komischen Dinge, die viele Leute verwenden.
Dann kann man Linux verwenden, ja.
Obhängig von bestimmter Software, die es oft unter Windows gab, hat sich die Welt heute etwas gewandelt.
Heutzutage vertrauen wir vermehrt auf Web-Dienste und auch Web-Technologien.
Insofern glaube ich, dass der Umstieg auf Linux heute leichter ist.
Krita ist ganz gut als Grafikprogramm.
Das kann man verwenden.
Als je zuvor.
Die Programmkompatibilität ist also heute nicht mehr so ein großes Thema.
Doch.
Das ist immer noch das größte Problem.
Krita.
Reichen wir aber zuerst über Deepin Linux an sich.
Die Installation auf meinem Thinkpad lief nach der Aktivierung von Secureboot reibungslos ab.
Die Startzeiten auf der SSD sind annehmbar schnell und die Performance des Systems kann sich absolut sehen lassen.
Was aber noch viel beeindruckender ist, das ist die Schönheit von Deepin Linux.
Bill Cosby würde dem System ganz sicher K.O.-Tropfen in den Drink schütten.
Diesen Ruf, die schönste Linux-Distribution zu sein, den hat sich das Betriebssystem redlich verdient.
Die Einstellungen befinden sich zum Beispiel nicht in einer klassischen App, sondern...
Chat, das habe ich mir auch gedacht gerade.
...quasi wie das Infocenter in Windows 10.
Dabei legen sich die Optionen mit einem Hauch Milchglaseffekt und Transparenz über den Desktop.
Die Einstellungen selbst...
Also was mir auf den Keks gegangen ist bei den Settings war, man hat ausgewählt, ich möchte Dark Scene verwenden und die Anwendungen waren danach nicht dark.
Man musste jede Anwendung extra umschalten auf dark.
Das hat mich ein bisschen verwirrt erstmal.
Die Einstellungen selbst sind nicht sehr umfangreich, aber dafür sehr einfach zu benutzen.
Ihr könnt einstellen, was ihr im Alltag braucht und mehr auch nichts.
Ich würde sagen, Deepin Linux ist damit ein selbst für Anfänger sehr leicht bedienbares System.
Ja, das stimmt, das fand ich auch.
Ich muss aber zugeben, dass mir paar Einstellungen einfach gefehlt haben.
Zum Beispiel war beim Touchpad das horizontale Scrollen deaktiviert und die Scrollgeschwindigkeit war unpräzise und viel...
Normie Laptops, wer verwendet Laptops?
Heute verwendet man Desktop-PCs oder Tablets oder Smartphones, Notebooks.
Klingt jetzt, als will ich mich darüber lustig machen, aber ernsthaft.
Ich hatte die letzten locker 10 Jahre kein Laptop.
Ich meine, ich habe auf der Arbeit einen Laptop, aber den verwende ich als Desktop, weil wir keine Desktops bekommen.
Viel zu schnell und ruckhaft, obwohl ich die langsamste Einstellung genutzt hatte.
Eine Google-Suche später und ich habe per Terminal das kleine Tool Deconf installiert,
wo ich mein Touchpad mein Wünschen entsprechend konfigurieren konnte.
Ich muss sagen...
Okay, hier hört es schon auf.
Das ist das, was den normalen Windows-Benehmigungen in der Laptop verwendet hat.
Das ist das, was den normalen Windows-Benutzern immer anpisst, wenn sie einen Terminal verwenden müssen.
Das nervt die immer.
Und das nervt die nicht, weil sie Terminal nervt.
Das nervt die Leute, weil sie Erfahrungen mit diesem Shit hier gemacht haben.
Das heißt, wer unter Windows als normaler Anwender mal gezwungen war, hier drin irgendwas zu machen,
er ist instant der Meinung, Terminal und CLI-Programme sind der allerletzte Bodensatz,
den es gibt, noch weniger als kacke.
Das liegt aber nicht daran, dass Kommando-Zeilen-Programme schlecht sind,
sondern, weil das Windows-Terminal und die Windows-CLI-Umgebung einfach die allerletzte Krütze sind.
Und selbst PowerShell ist zum Automatisieren gut.
Als interaktive Shell ist PowerShell kacke.
Und auch das Standard-Terminal mit dem PowerShell kommt, ist das gleiche kacke Terminal.
Das ist einfach crap. Das ist einfach absoluter Rotz.
Und deswegen haben Windows-Leute oftmals keinen Bock oder haben Panikzustände,
wenn sie einen Terminal aufmachen müssen unter Linux.
Bis sie dann irgendwann mal vielleicht, wenn sie sich darauf einlassen, drauf kommen,
dass das gar nicht so schlecht ist, weil es einfach deutlich besser ist als unter Windows.
Es ist echt toll, solche Freiheiten zu haben und unendliche Konfigurationsmöglichkeiten vorzufinden.
Insbesondere beim Touchpad, wäre mir aber lieber, es würde einfach funktionieren.
Nicht jeder Nutzer hat die Lust und die Zeit oder das technische Wissen, um das zu machen.
Da musst du dich unter Linux dran gewöhnen.
Ich bin mir aber absolut sicher, dass Huawei bei seinen eigenen Matebooks die Konfiguration perfekt macht.
Du kannst alles irgendwie einstellen.
Allerdings gut vorkonfiguriert und gut integriert zusammenarbeiten zwischen dem Programm ist halt einfach nicht drin.
Die Ärgernisse dort nicht hat.
Und dennoch, obwohl das Touchpad anfangs nicht ganz perfekt konfiguriert war,
haben die Gesten dennoch gut funktioniert.
Und das in der Sekunde.
Aristomat, also für NPM-Python und so, da kann ich nur empfehlen, dass man sich...
Gibt es da überhaupt eine Name für, was es global ist?
VNF ist es unter Python, also so ein Environment Manager installiert.
Dass man gar nicht mehr das System Node oder das System Python oder das System Rust oder was auch immer verwendet,
sondern quasi so ein Version Manager, der das für einen macht.
Das ist nämlich ganz praktisch.
Dann machst du eine VNF in Python oder hast du quasi in deinem Projektordner alles, was du brauchst,
ohne dein System zuzumüllen.
Ein Version Manager.
Ja Michael, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Versions du managen musst.
Also eine schon mal auf jeden Fall.
Nee, das war jetzt gemeiner.
Das kann ohne Treiberinstitution von Windows abgehen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele du da managen musst, aber...
Ich glaube, da brauche ich keinen Manager für.
Und dieses...
Das war jetzt fies, ich gebe es zu.
Leute, ich verschenke, ich verschenke einen Sub.
Ah ne, da bin ich ja schon ein Sub.
Max.
Okay.
Hey Max, ich benutze seit kurzem Linux Mint in einer VM.
Allerdings ist das Scrollen extrem langsam.
Weißt du, woran das liegt?
Du.
Boah, an der Maus vielleicht?
Manche Mäuse übertragen nicht so viel.
Michael, jetzt weiß ich dich...
Du darfst dir dann ein Emote aussuchen in Zukunft, okay?
Was wir machen.
Du darfst ein exklusives Emote aussuchen, was ich bei Fiverr mitbeauftrage.
Ja.
Ich will ja nicht, dass man mir hier irgendwie nachsagen kann,
ich würde die Leute flamen und dann...
Weep Emote please.
Virgin Emote, was auch immer ihr wollt.
Oder was auch immer er will, ist mir egal.
Hab damals immer deine YouTube Videos angesehen?
Ja, ich heiße hier nur ein bisschen anders.
Was du machen kannst, ist...
Für die Frage von der die kann, du kannst einstellen,
wie oft quasi, nennen wir es mal, die nach unten und oben Taste gedrückt wird
pro Mausradumdrehung unter Linux.
Kannst du machen. Kannst du an verschiedenen Stellen machen.
Wenn es dich hauptsächlich nervt im Browser, kannst du es im Browser einstellen.
Du kannst es auch irgendwie global einstellen.
Linux scroll wheel speed.
Damit geht es auf jeden Fall. Das ist so universell.
Da kannst du komplette Maus einstellen.
Ich müsste mal gucken, wo es genau geht, aber du kannst das einstellen.
Das habe ich auch gemacht in meiner VM für Chrome,
weil in Chrome hat er auch zu langsam gescrollt.
Chrome und Firefox haben eine interne Option für Mausradgeschwindigkeit.
Dafür habe ich einen Skript.
Allerdings muss ich das bei jedem Start neu ausführen.
Er lasse es doch beim Start automatisch ausführen.
Wenn man auf den Geräten ein ziemlich perfektes Benutzerlebnis bekommt,
und das direkt nach dem Auspacken.
Das Design der Apps und Icons passt wirklich gut zusammen.
Da merkt man echt, dass sich jemand absolut Mühe gegeben hat.
Blicke ich derweil auf das Design-Chaos in Windows 10,
wo jede einzelne App ihre eigene Definition von Dark Theme hat,
dann wird mir echt ein bisschen übel.
Das ist wirklich beeindruckend.
Das ist für mich als Windows-Nutzer schade zugleich.
Das ist auch nicht einheitlich.
Das einzige, wo das einheitlich ist,
sind wahrscheinlich mindestens mal die offiziellen Deepin-Apps.
Vielleicht, vielleicht noch ein paar Apps,
die sich gut mit GTK-Themes integrieren.
Aber spätestens, wenn ich irgendeine Electron-App öffne,
ist vorbei mit globalem Dark Theme.
Das ist eine chinesische Linux-Distribution.
Ohne wirklich keine Leibniz.
Jetzt kommen gerade wieder 30 Millionen Fragen im Chat.
Wie zufrieden bist du eigentlich mit deiner nicht mehr ganz so neuen Tastatur?
Du meinst hier mit der Logitech,
die ich jetzt hier...
Also ich habe die K95 abgelöst durch eine G513.
Ziemlich zufrieden.
Also einziges, was ein bisschen nervig ist,
ist die Leertaste.
Die ist ein ticken zu schwergängig,
ein bisschen zu C für meinen Geschmack.
Und das...
Ich zeige es euch mal.
Und was auch ein bisschen doof ist, ist das hier.
Dass die Handballenauflage man nicht fest...
Oh, Moment.
Huge, huge Niesen.
Dass die Handballenauflage keine Möglichkeit hat,
irgendwie an die Tastatur zu...
Attached zu werden.
Das ist doof.
Das heißt, ich bin alle...
20 Minuten immer mal beschäftigt,
das Ding neu auszurichten.
Tastatur und Handballenauflage.
Es ist aber gar nicht so schlimm,
weil das ist relativ schwergängig.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
wenn man spielt und das halt fest braucht,
dass man nicht ab und zu mal weggreifen muss von der Taste,
dann ist es vielleicht ein bisschen doof.
Man hat es trotzdem gehört,
trotzdem gemutet.
Hast du Linear, Clicky oder Taktil?
Ich habe...
Rommer.
Was sind Rommer?
Rommer G, oder wie das Zeug heißt.
Roamer.
Festkleben.
Nee, festkleben ist auch doof.
Wenn ich am Tisch festklebe,
dann kann ich das Ding ja nicht mehr bewegen.
Ich will es ja schon ab und zu mal bewegen können.
Und um es an Tastatur,
zwischen Tastatur und Pad fest zu kleben,
dafür ist die Auflagefläche zu klein.
Und nicht gerade genug.
Die ist auch schräg.
Das heißt, es hat faktisch überhaupt keinen Kontakt aneinander.
Ja, Magnet wäre gut gewesen,
aber Magnet haben sie nicht eingebaut.
Und man kann leider auch kein Magnet dranmoden oder so.
Reinmoden.
Also nicht einbauen, nein, wir moden, wenn schon.
So, da haben wir noch eine Frage.
Wie macht man das?
Kommt ein bisschen darauf an, was du verwendest.
Also bei mir, unter meinem Linux,
würde ich das einfach in mein X Startscript eintragen.
X in RC.
Und dann wäre das Ganze gestartet.
Je nachdem, was du verwendest,
wenn du eine normale Desktop-Distribution verwendest,
haben die alle in ihren Settings
sowas für Run Application at Login.
Also jedes Gnome, jedes KDE hat sowas.
Ich möchte als Quereinsteiger
bei einem zentralen Informatikdienst einsteigen.
Was ist denn das überhaupt?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Festkleben, das hält nicht.
Tischschrauben, ja Tisch festmachen bringt auch nichts,
weil ich will ja die Tastatur und die Unterlage doch verrücken können.
Ein zweites Mikro nimmt noch auf, ne.
Guck mal, wenn ich mich mute,
das liegt einfach daran, dass mein Mute-Switch kaputt ist.
Also der Mute-Switch muteet nicht so hundertprozentig.
Bauchschau.
Der ist nicht so ganz mute-sicher.
91% mute, genau.
Aber das passt, weil ich habe mein Noise-Gate drinne
und das ist meistens unterm Noise-Gate.
Tape unter Tastatur und Auflage.
Ne, ne, ich habe da keine Auflage drunter,
so war das nicht gemeint.
Ich würde schon die Tastatur gerne auf...
Ach so, eine Auflage drunter.
Ja, das könnte ich machen,
dann würde ich die Auflage rumschieben.
Das ist eine eigentlich ganz gute Idee.
Okay, gucken wir mal, fertig.
In welchem Alter hast du angefangen zu programmieren?
Ich kann dir sagen,
ich habe so richtig angefangen damals als C-Sharp 2,
also das.NET Framework 2 rausgekommen.
Ich habe so richtig angefangen,
aber davor habe ich schon ein bisschen mit C und Python rumgebastelt.
Also wahrscheinlich so...
Wahrscheinlich so 2001 rum, also so mit 16, 17 oder so.
Gibt es ein echtes Max FPS Revealed?
Ja, allerdings nicht in einem Video von mir,
sondern man muss halt genauer gucken.
Es gibt einige Videos, wo man nicht sieht,
aber es hat irgendwie keiner richtig gecheckt.
Hut ab, vor den Designern dieses Systems.
Die Schönheit von Deepin Linux ist allerdings nicht nur äußerlicher Natur.
Das Dock bietet zwei Darstellungsoptionen,
nicht zentriert und im Produktivitätsmodus,
wo es in Wahrheit ein bisschen wie Windows aussieht.
Das haben wir uns überhaupt nicht angeguckt.
Aber es ist super praktisch,
weil ich zumindest navigiere aufs Reflex mit der Maus immer nach unten links,
wo ich dann den Startknopf suche.
Drückt man die Windows-Taste,
dann öffnet sich das Launchpad von Deepin Linux,
wo alle eure reingelieferten Programme angezeigt werden.
Die Mauswege sind dann doch ein bisschen...
Ja klar.
Big Brain ist,
Windows-Taste D für Menü zu öffnen.
Aber das ist einfach nur bei mir so eingestellt.
Ich habe es bei mir so eingestellt, dass wenn ich,
also unter meinem i3,
wenn ich Windows-Taste D drücke,
dann, weil das ist halt schön nahe aneinander, die zwei Tasten,
dann geht ein Menü auf, wo ich Programme starten kann.
... länger als bei den Live-Tiles von Windows 10,
aber nachdem man dem Doc die wichtigsten Programme ablegen kann,
ist das im Alltag verkraftbar.
Praktisch ist auch,
dass viele Tastenkürzel von Windows in Linux übernommen worden sind.
2001 warst du 17, wenn ich mich nicht verrechnet habe.
Ich bin 84 geboren.
Quickmuffs müsste ich 2017 gewesen sein.
Oder?
Stimmt das, Leute?
Huge, huge, huge muffs.
Ja, stimmt.
Na ja, dann war ich 17.
Ja, ich bin auch nicht mehr so der Allerjüngste.
Ich bin jetzt 35, WTF.
... Windows und E, eröffnet den Windows Explorer.
Ich meine natürlich den Dateimanager.
Genau, Nautilus.
Das ist, aber er ist wirklich schön gestaltet.
Nein, das ist ein Reeskitter, Nautilus.
... deutlich übersetzt.
Und Nautilus, das ist der einzige Dateimanager,
den es so für Gnome ordentlich gibt.
Ich finde, Nautilus sackt.
Ich mag Nautilus überhaupt nicht.
Und eine der Gründe, warum ich Nautilus nicht mag, ist,
weil du erstmal Steuerung L drücken musst,
dass man hier oben den Fad eingeben kann.
Du wirkst jünger.
Ja, das ist auch gut.
Vielleicht gibt es mich auch noch eine Weile.
Also, ich bin ja kein großer Fan von Windows.
Aber, dass man hier oben den Fad direkt kopieren kann,
beziehungsweise über den Fad navigieren kann,
finde ich ganz praktisch.
Das geht mir bei Nautilus immer richtig auf den Keks.
Bei Nautilus muss man Steuerung L drücken.
Vielleicht gibt es ein Default-Setting.
Übrigens, man sieht hier auch, hier ist er in den gleichen,
gleiches merkwürdiges Verhalten reingelaufen, wie wir auch.
Er hat Darkseam eingestellt, aber man muss hier oben
erst pro Anwendung Darkseam umstellen.
Ansonsten muss ich euch ehrlich sagen,
wenn man Terminal-technisch ein bisschen geübt ist,
gibt es eigentlich überhaupt keine richtige
Daseinsberechtigung mehr für einen grafischen Explorer.
Man kann bestimmt auch rechts hier irgendwo hinklicken,
keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Ich benutze aber eh,
also wenn ich einen grafischen Explorer verwende für,
zum Beispiel, für eine Sache ist es ganz gut,
wenn man, wenn man schon mal einen grafischen Explorer
machen muss. Man muss zum Beispiel Track&Drop machen,
wenn man einfach aus VMWare auf das Haussystem
und zurückkopieren möchte.
Das geht zwar auch ohne, aber es geht mir
Track&Drop einfacher.
Da habe ich Tuna bei mir.
Aber ich verwende eigentlich so gut wie kein
grafischen Dateimanager, weil Terminal, wozu?
Weil man sich im Terminal halbwegs auskennt,
gibt es überhaupt keinen Grund, warum man
einen grafischen Dateimanager verwenden sollte.
Als der von Windows 10.
Es gibt doch Terminal.
Wie bei Mac OS, womit ihr bestimmte Dateien mit einer
Farbe markieren könnt, um sie später im Zusammenhang
mit irgendeiner Arbeit zum Beispiel leichter zu finden.
Das System Monitor von Deepin Linux ist wirklich
schlicht gestaltet, sieht trotzdem wundervoll aus.
Das finde ich übrigens gut, dass sie sowas drin haben.
Im Vergleich zu Windows hat er ein praktisches
Feature namens What You Click Is.
Das finde ich übrigens echt nicht schlecht,
dass sie sowas drin haben.
Das haben viele Linus Desktop Geschichten nicht dabei.
Ein ordentlicher System Monitor.
Was sage ich?
Lustig.
Dass gerade sowas basic mäßig ist, wo du vor allem
unter Linux zigtausend Informationen auslesen kannst
ohne Probleme, nicht bei allen dabei ist.
Es gibt oftmals nur sehr rudimentäre Dinge.
Natürlich, wo wir wieder mal am Thema sind,
wer einen Terminal aufhat und einfach mal Hardtop startet,
hat viel mehr Informationen und viel mehr Möglichkeiten
als mit so einem grafischen Tool.
Hat der Windows Explorer in Zwischen Tabs?
Nö.
This is what you kill.
Was ist das?
Hat der Windows Explorer in Zwischen Tabs?
Nö.
This is what you kill.
Was euch...
Äh, Stells an der Friseur will nicht.
... ihr das Programm schließen lässt, dass ihr anklickt.
Ich muss aber sagen, der Task Manager unter Windows 10
bietet deutlich mehr Informationen, zeigt Leistungsdaten
und Temperaturen an und bei Deepin Linux geht das einfach nicht.
Und da geht klar Form Over Function.
Da geht Terminal aufmachen und...
Dazu auch der Chrome Browser sowie die WPS Office Suite zählt.
Linux hat zwar einen eigenen Store, da ist aber scheiße.
Die Installation und alles funktioniert zwar zuverlässig,
aber dort finden sich nicht immer die aktuellsten Versionen der Apps.
Besonders beim Browser sollte man daher zum Beispiel
Flatpak installieren, wo es halt eine größere
und eine deutlich aktuellere Auswahl gibt.
Ja, kann man machen.
Das Problem ist hier, das muss man als Endkunde erst mal wissen.
Kann man machen, aber gerade Browser sollten immer aktuell sein.
Also es hat ja mittlerweile fast jede Distribution
so gemacht, dass Browser aktuell gehalten werden.
Und ich denke mal, das machen die hier, hoffe ich mal,
das machen die hier ähnlich.
Lange vorbei war, bevor Flatpak überhaupt rausgekommen ist,
musste ich das erstmal in Erfahrung bringen.
Es gibt also eine kleine Lernkurve, bis man zuverlässig...
Flatpak ist ein ganz guter Ansatz.
... Apps wie Telegram, Discord, Steam, VLC, Spotify und so weiter kommt.
Aber all diese Apps gibt es für Linux
und es ist wesentlich einfacher geworden, sie zu installieren,
als noch vor einigen Jahren.
Also mit Flatpak ist in Wahrheit...
Was ich ein bisschen kritisch sehe bei Flatpak und sowas ist,
gar nicht hat mit Flatpak selber überhaupt nichts zu tun,
sondern dass der Trend unter Linux mittlerweile auch zu
Custom Package Managern geht.
Du hast quasi den offiziellen Paketmanager von einer Distribution.
Dann hast du NPM.
Dann hast du deine Ruby Gems.
Dann hast du PIP, NVM, RustUp, Flatpak, Snap,
alle möglichen Dinger.
Das heißt im Endeffekt brauchst du...
Oder bräuchte man, eigentlich bräuchte man mittlerweile
schon wieder so einen Metapackage Manager.
Und so wie ich die Leute in der Linux kenne,
hat das wahrscheinlich auch schon irgendjemand gebastelt.
Dass es wahrscheinlich einen Package Manager gibt,
der alle Package Manager Package managert.
Webpack gibt es auch noch. Nougat, genau.
Also wahrscheinlich gibt es mittlerweile unter Linux...
Also mich würde wundern, wenn das nicht schon einer gebaut hätte,
einen Metapackage Manager, der alle Package Manager Package managt.
Oder man macht sich einfach einen Skript.
Also mit Flatpak ist es in Wahrheit mindestens
genauso einfach wie bei Windows.
Besser, besser.
Also einen Vorteil hat diese ganzen Package Manager
im Vergleich zu der Windows Installation Geschichte.
Unter Windows gehst du ins Internet,
legst dir was runter und dann war's das.
Hat dieses Programm keinen Custom Updater dabei,
bleibt es immer auf der Version, die du installiert hast.
Du bekommst nie mit, wenn es Sicherheitslücken gibt.
Du bekommst nie mit, wenn es neue Updates gibt.
Es bleibt einfach diese Version und fertig.
Das ist mit allen diesen Package Manager besser.
Du kannst zentral deine Pakete updaten,
du kannst zentral gucken, ob es Updates gibt.
Du kannst zentral gucken, ob es was Neues gibt im Endeffekt.
Und unter Windows...
Das ist eines der größten Probleme,
die ich persönlich unter Windows habe, ist...
Software aktualisieren.
So was Simples, so was Einfaches.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Sachen
ich nicht wieder angefasst habe nach dem Installieren.
Zum Beispiel, ich hab mal irgendwann diese Intel...
Diese Intel CPU Tools installiert,
und seitdem hab ich die nicht wieder aktualisiert.
Warum hab ich die nicht wieder aktualisiert?
Weil das Ding halt einfach installiert wurde
und keine Updatefunktion hat
und nicht in dem Package Manager drin ist und nichts.
Gibt so was unter Windows?
Es gibt für Entwicklertools...
Es gibt zwei Sachen.
Es gibt...
In welchem Ordner gibts denn der da rum?
Es gibt Scoop.
Das ist für Entwicklertools und nur für deinen User.
Und es... Nee, nee, nee.
Matt, das suckt.
Das suckt.
Das hab ich schon ausgebildet, das ist kacke.
Es gibt Choco und es gibt Scoop.
Die beiden Sachen sind ganz gut.
Choco ist für die...
Zeig's euch mal.
Verwend ich übrigens nicht.
Choco ist für systemweite Installation ganz gut.
Die haben auch sehr viel Zeugs drin.
Hier kannst du auch sehen.
Choco ist für Betriebssystem weiter ganz gut.
Allerdings Scoop finde ich persönlich schöner,
weil es nur für den jeweiligen User installiert.
Du brauchst auch keine Atmenberechtigung oder sowas.
Wenn du dir einen neuen Chrome installieren willst,
einen neuen Chromium, kannst du es einfach hier drüber machen
und alles Mögliche.
Was haben wir denn hier gerade?
Warum schreib ich mal Scoop?
Alter.
Was haben wir denn installiert?
Aktuell haben wir hier gerade...
Über Scoop hab ich hier gerade installiert.
7zip, ich wusste gar nicht, dass ich eine Arduino-Idee drauf hab.
Die Shell, was auch immer dark ist.
FFmpeg, Git, den Hex-Editor.
Irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten.
IPerf für Netzwerk-Mess.
Irgendwie einen komischen Installer.
Node.js.
Ach so, für Postman.
Ein Programm, um Get und Post, HTTP, Get und Post zu machen.
Eine uralte Python-Version.
Das stimmt gar nicht.
Die letzte Python-Zweierversion, die es gibt.
SQLite, Browser, Streamlink, VLC, VS Code, Yarn und YouTube-Download.
So.
Und das ist halt ganz praktisch, weil ich kann jetzt einfach sagen, Scoop Update.
Dann guckt ihr, ob es was Neues gibt.
Und sagt, aha, ja, gibt es.
Also haben wir hier oben schon gemacht.
Ähm...
Wir sehen nichts.
Ich hab eine Stream-Vorschau an.
Ihr seht alles, was ich auch sehe.
Ja, zumindest kann ich jetzt sagen, Update alles.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das überhaupt hier braucht.
Update alles.
Und jetzt update er den ganzen installierten Shit.
Gut.
Sachen, die laufen, kann er nicht updaten.
Das ist noch ein bisschen blöd.
Aber das meine ich halt.
Es ist bei weitem nicht so schön, wie das unter Linux mit dem zentralen Paket-Manager ist.
Aber ich mein, weil unter der Haube ist es im Prinzip immer noch ein Custom-Repo.
Ähm...
Ein Custom-Repo, der sich aus dem Internet Sachen runterlädt.
Der riesen Vorteil von Paket-Managern unter Linux mit offiziellen Paket-Quellen.
Ich glaub, ich muss das noch mal kurz hier machen.
Weil der wollte grad mein...
... mein Terminal aktualisieren, was ja nicht funktioniert.
So, gut.
Der riesen Vorteil unter Linux und dem Paket-Manager von Linux ist,
dass... ähm... sie eben offizielle Paket-Quellen haben.
Und auch die Pakete da drinnen quasi per mit... mit... äh...
Checksummen geprüft werden, ob das die echten, richtigen, offiziellen Pakete sind.
Das heißt, Scoop downloaded unter der Haube immer noch, dafür halt schön... schön vereint in einem Programm.
Unter der Haube downloaded Scoop immer noch die Sachen von quasi der offiziellen Seite.
Sollte auf der offiziellen Seite, mal beispielsweise...
nehmen wir mal 7-Zip als Beispiel, ja,
sollten die 7-Zip-Hersteller jetzt mal ihr Passwort verlieren
oder ihr Passwort irgendwo im Internet stehen haben
und irgendjemand könnte eine 7-Zip-Version veröffentlichen mit Virus,
dann würde das Scoop genauso installieren,
wie wenn man das manuell von der Webseite installieren würde.
Und das kann ja halt bei einem Linux Paket-Manager nicht passieren,
es sei denn, das offizielle Repo wird gehackt.
Da kannst du dir sicher sein, dass du immer die offiziellen Pakete kriegst,
was es dann schon noch ein bisschen besser macht.
Max FPS, wie kommst du da drauf? Kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Nope. Ich höre mich nur ähnlich an.
Ich meine, ich hab zwar den gleichen Hintergrund und das gleiche Logo, aber...
Okay, wir wollten das Video weitergucken.
Ich hab nur das Gaming Kicks gesehen und bin sofort draufgegangen.
Big Brain.
Nein.
... wie man zu Flatback kommt und dass es überhaupt existiert.
Aber es gibt halt leider immer noch Programme, wo das nicht ganz so einfach ist.
Ich sag euch ganz ehrlich, hätte ich meinen gesamten Workflow von Windows auf Linux übertragen können,
hätte absolut nichts gegen einen Verbleib bei Deepin gesprochen.
Leider gibt es halt die Adobe Creative Cloud immer noch nicht,
was für die Linux Community meiner Meinung nach echt unendlich schade ist.
Nicht nur die Creative Cloud gibt es nicht. Es gibt sehr viel unter Linux nicht.
Als ehemaliger Windows Phone User weiß ich echt gut, wie es ist,
von bestehenden App-Anbietern ausgeschlossen zu werden.
Und die Creative Cloud nutze ich halt wirklich jeden Tag.
Aber ich weiß auch, es gibt Alternativen für Linux und sogar welche,
die keine 60€ im Monat kosten.
Zum Beispiel Greta statt Photoshop.
Greta ist gut, hab ich vorhin auch gesagt.
Audacity ist ein wirklich guter Konkurrenz zur Audition.
Audacity suckt, Alter.
Ich mein, ernsthaft.
Guckt euch dieses Ding an.
Und guckt euch das da an.
So.
Also mal ernsthaft.
Audacity kannst du schön verwenden,
um einfach in einem Mikrofon-Stream aufzuzeichnen.
Vielleicht die einen oder anderen Billig-Effekte.
Aber ganz ehrlich.
Ich glaube Audacity hat noch nicht mal Plugins für...
Wie heißt das Workstation?
Wie heißt diese Schnittstelle für Audio-Workstation-Plugins?
Chat, ihr wisst das doch.
VST.
VST? Ich glaube VST, das klingt gut.
Nicht MIDI.
Ich glaube VST, ich glaube VST ist es.
Ich glaube in Audacity kann man noch nicht mal richtig
irgendwelche Audio-Plugins installieren.
Hat das? Okay, dann habe ich nichts gesagt.
Und für Videobearbeitung habe ich mir Davinci Resolve ausgesucht.
Und ich war echt bereit Premiere Pro dafür den Laufpass zu geben.
Aber leider funktioniert das Programm unter Linux
ausschließlich mit NVIDIA Grafik.
Ja, ich habe echt alles probiert.
Alles mögliche über das Terminal installiert und stundenlang in vorn gelesen.
Aber es scheint mit Intel Integrated Chips einfach nicht zu gehen.
Und das ist unendlich schade.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass Davinci Resolve
für mich Premiere Pro ersetzen könnte.
Und dieses Video werde ich auch darauf bearbeiten.
Aber Mangelkompatibilität mit der Hardware, die ich habe,
eben unter Windows 10.
Deepin Linux ist ein wunderschönes, wirklich übersichtliches
und leicht zu bedienendes Betriebssystem.
Man muss den Entwicklern und auch der Linux Community
echt ein großes Kompliment dazu machen.
Die Linux Community hat ja in dem Fall wirklich gar nichts damit zu tun.
Also dem Hersteller muss man echt ein Kompliment machen.
Also wir haben es uns ja am letzten Stream auch angeguckt.
Das war wirklich gut.
Was sich in den letzten Jahren getan hat.
Im Vergleich zu Windows 10 spricht grundsätzlich mal das Design,
aber auch die superleichte Bedienung für Deepin.
Es ist einfach von der Gestaltung so unglaublich benutzerfreundlich.
Wenn man nur grundlegende Sachen verwendet,
ist Linux meiner Meinung nach locker bereit für die Masse
und Huawei macht nichts falsch, Deepin auf seine Matebooks zu installieren.
Linux hat aber für mich noch zwei große Schwächen.
Das einzige, also eines der Hauptprobleme, die ich sehe,
was für Mainstream Benutzer gegen Linux spricht.
Es gibt viele Sachen, die dafür sprechen.
Zum Beispiel, lassen wir uns keine Viren einfangen.
Die dagegen sprechen sind zum Beispiel Steuersoftware.
Viele machen ihre Steuererklärungen mit keinem anderen Wieso-Sparbuch.
Ne, wie heißt das Wieso-Steuer-Dings oder Bool-Tax oder was es da nicht alles gibt.
Geht halt nicht unter Linux.
Geht nur mit irgendwelchem Wine rumgefrickelt.
Das würde ich mal nicht unter ordentlichem Support abhaken.
Man kann mit Wine relativ viel machen,
aber das ist dann wirklich Frickelland anstatt,
dass es wirklich gut funktioniert.
Also Wein würde ich da mal nicht mit zählen.
Ja, es gehen auch einige Spiele mit diesem neuen Walkenzeug und Proton.
Das macht ja auch eine 0x15-NOOP-Benutzer nicht.
Es fehlt einfach relativ viel,
was so normale Benutzer gerne verwenden wollen.
Wenn sich jemand wirklich nur YouTube-Videos anguckt
und E-Mails schreibt und Spotify hört,
das sind wirklich nur diese absolut grundlegenden NOP-Sachen,
dann kann der ohne Probleme Linux auf dem Desktop verwenden.
Aber der sollte nicht auf die Idee kommen, an dem bei was spielen zu wollen.
Und die meisten Leute dienen Desktop recht Office.
Wobei man sagen muss, ich verwende ja eh kein Office.
Da bin ich da falsch für.
Genau, viele wollen auch noch Microsoft Office verwenden.
Wobei ich glaube, dass es mittlerweile mit der über die 365 Cloud
ganz okay funktioniert im Browser.
Glaube ich, habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Das ist wohl ganz, ganz gut.
Genau, da kannst du auch ein Tablet verwenden.
Das heißt, die meisten Leute, die ein Desktop-Rechner haben,
die wollen halt ab und zu auch mal ein bisschen was spielen.
Die wollen auch vielleicht mal irgendwie mit Affinity Designer
ein paar, keine Ahnung, Bildchen bearbeiten, machen, was auch immer.
Unter Linux kommst du halt immer zwischendurch oft an den Punkt,
wo du als NOP was machen müsstest, was entweder viel Gefrickel erfordert
oder so diese eine kleine Nischensache,
die du halt machen möchtest, weil es halt für dich wichtig ist, nicht geht.
Es gibt viele Gründe, die für Lidung sprechen,
aber es gibt auch vor allem für so die Casual-Alwände auch einiges,
wo sie Probleme mit haben.
Die eine ist die etwas schwergängige Kompatibilität.
Um da Vinci Resolve überhaupt installieren zu können,
musste ich schon mal mehrere Pakete im Terminal installieren.
Und um es dann zum Starten zu bringen...
Das ist auch wieder so ein Punkt, da hat er recht, da hat er vollkommen recht.
Aber die Linux-Fans, die sehr ideologisch da eingeschworen sind auf Linux-Beste,
die auch nicht zugeben können, dass es sinnvoll ist,
das passende Tool für die passende Sache zu verwenden,
die würden jetzt anders argumentieren.
Und zwar, er sagte hier...
Um das zu können, musste ich schon mal mehrere Pakete im Terminal installieren.
Er sagte hier, da Vinci Resolve funktioniert nicht richtig unter Linux,
weil er muss mehrere Pakete installieren.
Der Hardcore-Linux-Fanboy würde jetzt so argumentieren,
das ist nicht die Schuld von Linux.
Fertig Diskussion.
Und das ist meiner Ansicht nach die Einstellung,
die unter anderem dafür sorgt, dass wir mit dem normalen Desktopbetrieb
nicht weiterkommen unter Linux.
Deswegen geht nichts...
Richtig, genau.
Hier.
Linux hat aber für mich noch zwei große Schwächen.
Die eine ist die etwas schwergängige Kompatibilität.
Die eine ist die etwas schwergängige Kompatibilität
und dann sagt er, Vinci Resolve ging nicht richtig.
Und dann sagt der Hardcore-Linux-Fanboy, das liegt nicht an Linux.
Streng genommen haben die ja recht.
Das liegt daran, dass wahrscheinlich Vinci Resolve das nicht ordentlich programmiert hat.
Aber die haben mit Sicherheit nicht einfach gesagt,
ach ne, das machen wir nicht,
sondern wahrscheinlich ist einfach die Sache drum herum für sie entweder nicht wichtig genug
oder zu kompliziert oder die Technik nicht da oder was auch immer.
Man kann unter Linux sich sehr oft damit rausreden,
so nach dem Motto, ja das ist nicht die Schuld von Linux.
Aber das hilft demjenigen, der irgendwas machen will, nicht.
Um Vinci Resolve überhaupt installieren zu können,
musste ich schon mal mehrere Pakete im Terminal installieren.
Arkenas neue 99-Taliste.
Und um es dann zum Starten zu bringen, dann gefühlt nochmals weitere 100 Pakete.
Nur damit ich am Ende eine Fehlermeldung bekomme, dass es nicht starten kann.
Und die zweite Schwäche ist ein bisschen die Stabilität.
Schon klar, mein Laptop wurde für Windows optimiert und auch damit ausgeliefert.
Aber das Finkpad T480 zählt zu den besten Linux Laptops, die es zu kaufen gibt.
Und trotzdem hängt sich der Laptop fast immer auf.
Wisst ihr, was man da jetzt eigentlich machen müsste?
Man müsste da mal ein Manjaro oder so installieren mit aktuellem Kernel.
Und ich könnte wetten, die Bugs wären nicht mehr da.
Bei Linux macht es, gerade bei Hardware Support macht es sehr viel aus,
was du für eine Kernel-Version hast.
Auch wieder so eine Geschichte.
Was ist das schwarze, das da?
Das ist eine Docking-Station, das geht hier unten weiter.
Da ist ein Stromanschluss und ein paar Netzwerkanschlüsse und so für das Notebook.
Wenn ich einen externen Monitor per USB-C Docking anschließe.
Oder er erkennt anfangs das Dock gar nicht.
Was ist das für ein roter Knopf?
Das ist der IBM, der Lenovo Touch-Nipple.
So ein Joystick ist das im Endeffekt.
So ein Mini-Joystick für die Maus.
Die Maus lässt sich damit übrigens viel schöner bewegen als mit dem Trackpad.
Manche Systemprogramme starten selbst bei einem frisch installierten System nicht.
Und das, obwohl ich diese Programme genau bräuchte, um meinen Linux-Benutzer erleben zu können.
Willkommen unter Linux auf dem Laptop.
Was das Design auf den ersten Blick auch sein mag.
Auch hier gibt es Dinge, die nicht ausgereift sind.
Zum Beispiel lässt sich das Film immer noch nicht global für alle Apps ändern.
Das alles zusammen, insbesondere Arbeitsstabilitätsprobleme, waren ziemlich ärgerlich.
Windows ist auch nicht perfekt, aber wenn ich eine frische Installation habe,
dann sollte doch im Regelfall die mitgelieferte Systemsoftware starten.
Und ich weiß, die Entwickler von Deepin haben vielleicht ein Hunderttausendstel der Mittel,
die im Microsoft zur Verfügung stehen.
Und dafür ist es echt verdammt gut.
Nur hoffe ich, dass es bei Hoorways Laptops solche Marken einfach nicht gibt.
Also kritisieren kann man den nicht aktuellen App Store,
dass man noch relativ viele Sachen einfach per Hand konfigurieren muss,
was nicht jeder Nutzer oder bzw. normalen Verbraucher wirklich kann.
Und ein paar kleinere Problemchen mit der Software.
Die kann man aber als erfahrener Nutzer sicherlich mit etwas Zeit beheben,
aber ich persönlich sag's euch ganz ehrlich, ich würde mir das nicht antun.
Wenn Hoorway aber seinen Job richtig macht und sich echt bemüht,
dass solche Dinge richtig konfiguriert sind,
dann kann man es als Endkunde produktiv einsetzen.
Für mich ist es aber zu viel Stress und selbst nach einigen Stunden der Arbeit
war das System immer noch nicht so konfiguriert.
Einige Stunden? Du kannst da Monate dran rumwasseln.
Das ist halt der Vor- und Nachteil von Linux.
Kifkin, Twitch Prime, fünf Monate, danke schön.
Dass ich meine Hardware ohne Kompromisse verwenden konnte.
Deepin ist einfach noch nicht so ausgereiht wie manche andere Linux-Distributionen
und auch nicht wie Windows 10.
Das kann man leider einfach nicht abstreiten.
Dennoch, den Entwicklern muss man ein großes Kompliment machen.
Hätte Windows so viel Liebe zum Detail und ein so schönes Design,
wäre es für mich das beste Betriebssystem der Welt.
Und allein das sagt mir schon,
Hoorway macht absolut nichts falsch mit Deepin Linux.
Vor allem, weil sich die Probleme, die ich hatte,
auch noch ein bisschen Optimierung lösen lassen.
Was die Kompatibilität betrifft, bin ich ziemlich sicher,
dass sich Linux in den nächsten Jahren noch ordentlich besser wird.
Blick, GP, Twitch Prime, huge sub.
Danke schön, drei Monate.
Und vielleicht hat auch dieses Handelsverbot im Endeffekt
für die Open-Source-Software-Community doch etwas Gutes.
Unter Linux-Fans gibt es ja diesen Running-Gag.
Da spricht man immer wieder vom Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Es war 2003, glaube ich, haben einige Medien das zum ersten Mal berichtet.
Da hieß es, 2004 wird das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Da ist es total am Blödsinn.
Da wird sich Linux endgültig gegen Windows durchsetzen.
Und jedes Jahr darauf wurde das erneut berichtet.
Manchmal auch fast schon ein bisschen ironisch.
Denn gekommen ist dieses Jahr bisher ja nicht.
Wenn auch Linux heute eine größere Rolle spielt als je zuvor.
Was zum Teufel ist der Hype-Train?
Was ist das? Was ist der Hype-Train?
Ich habe keinen Schirmer, was denn das überhaupt ist?
Der Hype-Train.
Daddy Khan, warum er Windows nicht selbst installiert?
Wahrscheinlich weil er keinen Moment, keinen Pure-Way-Laptop hat.
Und Android basiert auch auf Linux.
Silver Dark, dankeschön, zwei Monate.
100% der Hype-Train.
Moonwie, Twitch Prime.
Der Hype-Train sorgt dafür, dass Leute subben.
Ich mag den Hype-Train.
Ich weiß nicht, was der Hype-Train ist, aber huge.
Dankeschön für die Subs.
Denn die korrekte Aussprache ist Pure-Way.
Pure-Way, haben wir vorhin gelernt.
Das war's dann auch schon von mir.
Wenn euch das Video nicht gefallen hat, dann wisst ihr natürlich, was zu tun ist.
Aber wenn doch, dann gebt uns doch einen Daumen rauf und abonniert unseren Kanal.
Ah hier, da hat einer Link gepostet.
Linux auf dem Desktop, wahrscheinlich ist der Vortrag wieder 50 Minuten oder 37 Minuten.
Hat denn schon jemand geguckt? Taucht der?
Ich meine, er ist nicht so lang, 30 Minuten.
Vielleicht sogar weniger, da ist immer noch eine Fragerunde dabei.
Linux auf dem Desktop.
Es geht um Wayland, oh Gott, Wayland.
Der Rohrkrepierer.
Alter, MonkaS-Musik.
Mit, das ist auch so ein Problem, was sie unter Linux haben, ne?
X11, da traut sich, beziehungsweise XOR, da traut sich keiner mehr dran, zu Recht.
Wayland ist so wir und nach irgendwie 13 Jahren immer noch nicht richtig verbreitet.
Oder will auch keiner so richtig dran.
Herzlich willkommen zum nächsten Talk mit einem echten Dauerbrenner-Thema.
Linux auf dem Desktop.
Persönlich habe ich das Gefühl, 2019 war es immer noch nicht so weit.
Aber ganz kurz, wer benutzt denn aktuell Linux auf dem Desktop?
Also bei mir ist es so, zählt das, zählt das, wenn ich Linux in der VM habe?
Ist das Linux auf dem Desktop?
Knallibeer, Stufe 1, 2 Monate, Dankeschön, Pock.
Zählt nicht, okay.
Ach, irgendjemand hat vorhin gefragt, wie das mit GPU-Durchreichen in die VM geht?
Also unter Linux geht das nicht.
Unter Linux funktioniert das ganz gut, wenn du KVM verwendest oder sogar VirtualBox kann das mittlerweile.
Funktioniert das ganz gut mit GPU-Durchreichen in die VM, hat aber auch so seine Tücken und ist nicht so schön integriert.
Zum Beispiel kannst du natürlich nicht GPU-Durchreichen in eine VM und die VM dann gescheit bedienen über den normalen Monitor.
Also schön, es ist auch nicht so schön.
Es sind eigentlich, GPU durch, VM mit durchgereichter GPU sind im Prinzip zwei Rechner.
Du brauchst eine zweite Tastatur, du brauchst einen zweiten Monitor.
Okay, gut, vielleicht habe ich doch unrecht gehabt und 2019 war endlich das Jahr des Linux auf dem Desktop, aber mal sehen.
Das stimmt doch, das stimmt.
Genau, Näheres dazu wird uns gleich Uetwilt erzählen.
Es gibt so ein paar, es gibt so ein paar Tricks, dass du mit, ich glaube Clares, Clares heißt das Ding,
dass du da relativ performant den Framebuffer abgreifen kannst von der Grafikkarte,
aber das würde ich mal nicht als schöne Lösung sehen, wenn man der Performance halber Spiel in der VM spielt.
Alleine für das Halbtrain-Feature muss man als Entwickler Summen.
Stufe 2 abgeschlossen, das ist ja der richtige Gebate von Twitch, Alter.
PySix, Dankeschön.
Du kannst einfach einen USB-Control durchreiten, einfach deine Tastatur umstecken, ja, das macht es natürlich viel besser.
Ganz kurz ein Hinweis zum Ablauf des Talks, der Talk ist in fünf Teilen untergliedert, wir machen eine kurze Frage- und Antwortenrunden nach jedem Blog.
Das heißt, wenn ein Blog zu Ende ist, bitte ich euch möglichst zügig zu einem der beiden Saalmikrofone zu laufen oder währenddessen...
Wir spüren mal vor, wo es losgeht.
Total überrascht, dass so viele Leute gekommen sind.
Ah, jetzt geht es los.
Ohje, das ist wieder so einer, der rumschmatzt, glaube ich.
Ohje, Leute.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man uns das angucken soll.
Klingt nach Blattlos, hat jetzt schon jemand geguckt, den Talk, ob man sich den geben kann.
Hansa81, zwei Monate, Dankeschön.
Wir kommen, wir spüren mal ein bisschen vor.
Oh, nee, History von X brauche ich jetzt nicht.
History von X brauche ich nicht.
Also ich hätte jetzt gerne einen Vortrag gehabt, wo er sich drüber aufregt,
ob der Stand von Linux auf dem Desktop ist, zumindest im klassischen Bereich.
Eben auf dem Desktop, PC, zu dem, was halt Noobs so machen.
Wenn man was programmieren will, wenn man netzwerktechnisch was macht, ist das Linux auf dem Desktop eine super Geschichte.
Aber für so eine 0815 Noob, der daheim am Rechner sitzt und einfach nur seine fünf Sachen machen will, der hat halt Probleme.
Guck dir doch Linux Sachs an. Das ist tatsächlich ein guter Vortrag, der geht aber länger.
Und der Titel gebated auch, weil, das ist übrigens wirklich ein guter Vortrag, den kenne ich, den habe ich schon vor einer ganzen Weile mal geguckt.
Das ist ein wirklich guter Vortrag, weil die sind halbe halbe, wirklich, das ist gebated.
Der Vortrag geht zur Hälfte, warum Linux sackt, und danach die gleichen Punkte, warum das eigentlich ganz gut ist.
How to make Cola
Ok, wir gucken, dass wir mal Cola machen.
Zum Glück sagt der Cola, ansonsten sagen alle, Moment, ob ich das emote, ansonsten sagen alle im Kokonaland immer Coke.
Da sagt keiner mehr Cola, sondern Coke.
I need Coke
Big brain Mörser. Ich habe gar keinen Mörser.
CD?
Euro an essential oils. Ich habe anstatt mein eigenes 7x Flavorkompon zu machen,
mit den eigentlichen Ingenieuren, die die essential oils machen. Und das war ein bisschen mehr
Arbeit, aber ich meine, in der Ende funktioniert es genauso. Also brauchen wir die folgenden
Ingenieuren, um den Flavorkompon zu machen. Wir brauchen 10 Gramm Orangepiele,
wir brauchen 10 Gramm Lemonpiele, wir brauchen 4 Gramm Cinnamon, das ist ungefähr ein
Stick, wir brauchen ungefähr 1 Gramm Nutmeg, 1 Gramm Koriandersez, und letztendlich 4
Gramm Neroli oder bitteren Orangepiele. Aber ich konnte diese wirklich nicht finden,
das ist mir zu kompliziert, das ist mir zu big brain. Was hat er da eigentlich für eine
stylische Waage? Oh Waage! Leute, ich zeige euch mal was. Und zwar, man kann die aktuellen
Xiaomi Wagen, kann man mit einem ESP32, was das mit der Waage zu tun hat, weiß ich auch
nicht so genau. Man kann mit einem ESP32, die über Bluetooth auslesen, diese Wagen.
Was sehr nice ist, weil dann kann man die nicht zu wiegen verwenden von sich selber,
sondern man kann da beispielsweise eine Kiste mit Wasserflaschen drauf stellen und man kann
dann automatisch auslesen, wann man wieder Wasser kaufen muss. So was, oder Saftflaschen,
oder irgendwas. Also sprich, irgendwas, was mit der Zeit, Katzenfutter zum Beispiel. Ich
habe mir jetzt eine bestellt, die werden wir dann auch im Stream in Betrieb nehmen und
gucken, wie man das ganze programmieren kann. Und da kann man quasi alles, wo man irgendwie
anhand des Gewichts ab den Füllstand ablesen kann, kann man dann gut in seine Heimautomatisierung
integrieren. Unnötig, haha, das ist alles. Letztendlich ist außer schlafen, essen, sonst
ist alles unnötig. Das werden wir dann, wenn es da ist, im Stream machen. Halten solche
Wagen dann eine dauerhafte Belastung ab? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Also die können
bestimmt eine dauerhafte Belastung ab, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die dadurch
ungenau werden. Oder nicht mal richtig funktionieren. Mal gucken, mal gucken, wie das ganze funktioniert.
Ich würde mal ausprobieren, wie es funktioniert. Wenn es nicht funktioniert, habe ich halt
30 Euro rausgehauen, aber ich meine, who cares. Haha, dafür, guck mal, 30 Euro habe ich durch
die Subsäule schon wieder drin, das ist kein Problem. Gehen die Batterien nicht leer?
Vielleicht kann man da auch USB oder so zum Laden anschließen. Ich weiß es nicht. Muss
man mal ausprobieren.
Warum soll ich eigentlich mal eine eigene Cola machen?
Ich trinke überhaupt keine Cola.
Das sieht aus, als wäre ich in Frankfurt am Willy-Brandt-Platz gefahren und hätte
mal einmal mit der Schippe über den Platz gefahren und hätte es dann abgekocht. Sieht
aus wie Bodendreck aus Frankfurt.
Was ist das denn? Irgendwelche Kräutermischung, wo man Cola draus machen will?
Cola?
Also noch sieht es nicht nach Cola aus, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Haha.
Ohne Zucker schmeckt es wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Diabetes-Drink.
Oh, da hätte ich ja Bock drauf, den Topf danach sauber machen zu müssen.
So, ja.
Ah, das wird danach nochmal verdunnt.
Es sieht halt echt aus wie Cola, ne?
Ja, gut. Also wenn man Cola trinkt, kann man das ja...
Aber ich trinke weder Cola noch irgendwie andere. Das ist wirklich etwas, wo ich echt
gesund bin in der Richtung. Ich trinke eigentlich fast nur Wasser und Tee. Dafür ist der Rest
ungesund genug.
YouTube.
What? Ah, hab mich vertippt.
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Was haben wir sonst noch so hier für Videos am Start?
Ego-Shooter 2020. Why Windows...
Windows ist überhaupt nicht free. Totaler Blödsinn.
Der Thermaltake, 5,52 drive bei Zigarettenanzünder, was auch immer.
Irgendein Bethesda, warum Bethesda sackt Video, das können wir uns mal wieder angucken.
Oder Battlefield-Topplay.
Wir gucken uns erstmal ein Bethesda Flame Video an.
Das ist sogar auf Deutsch.
Da spricht aber das alles äußerst korrekt und entspannt aus.
Den halte ich nicht aus.
Ich habe die Berichterstattung nicht erfolgt und habe mich fast gänzlich aus dem Bereich zurückgezogen.
Die Berichterstattung über die Macher der Fallout und Elder Scrolls Reihe ist im Grunde genommen noch dieselbe wie vor meiner Auszeit.
Eine Negativschlagzeile jagt die nächste.
Seit den Teasern auf der E3 2018 herrscht Funkstille zu Starfield und Elder Scrolls 6.
Zu Starfield erscheinen immer wieder kurze, kontextlose Interviewfetzen, die nichts Gutes erahnen lassen.
Zuletzt erzählte Todd Howard beispielsweise, dass man Test 6 als ein 10-Jahres-Spiel plane, was in meinen Ohren die Alarmglocken schälen lässt.
Skyrim ist auch ein 10-Jahres-Spiel geworden, aber nicht wegen dem, was der Hersteller alles eingebaut hat, sondern wegen den Möglichkeiten, die der Hersteller eingebaut hat und was die Community draus gemacht hat.
Sie haben das ja auch schon versucht mit diesem...
Es gab doch diesen Skyrim-Mod-Store.
Es gab doch diesen Skyrim-Community-Store oder sowas, was sie dann eingeführt haben, wo man quasi für die gleichen Mods jetzt was bezahlen sollte.
Und wer hätte es gedacht, es wollte kein Mensch haben?
Der Entwickler, der einst mit jedem neuen Spiel neue Maßstäbe gesetzt hat.
Der einen Preis nach dem anderen gewonnen hat und der Spieler bei jedem Release in Extrasse versetzt hat.
Das stimmt.
Etwas ist verloren gegangen.
Die haben ziemlich viele Game of the Years gewonnen.
Also auch mit Fallout.
Und in diesem Video möchte ich mir einmal mit euch anschauen, was das war und wie es um die Zukunft des Entwicklers und seiner Spiele steht.
Und da wir gerade kurz vor Weihnachten stehen, habe ich dieses Video in Anlehnung an Charles Dickens Weihnachtsgeschichte strukturiert...
Oh, big brain!
...beginnend mit dem Bethesda der vergangenen Tage.
Das 1986 in Bethesda...
Wer ist auch am Start?
...Bethesda Softworks verbrachte seine ersten Jahre mit der Entwicklung von Franchise-Spielen wie Terminator oder Wayne Gretzky Hockey.
Wayne Gretzky Hockey.
Gibt es den Typen überhaupt noch?
...begeben sie sich in die Welt der Rollenspiele.
Das ist ja so der Ober-Eis-Hockey-Man.
...sollte ursprünglich ein 3D-Gladiatoritspiel werden. Daher auch der Name.
Doch am Laufe der Entwicklung verschob sich der Fokus und wurde zu einem RPG mit einer riesigen Welt.
Bedingt durch den langen Entwicklungsprozess verpassten sie das wichtige Weihnachtsgeschäft und konnten erst im Frühjahr des Folgejahres in den Verkauf starten.
Das ist ja schon uralt.
Intern gingen bereits Vorrelease von einem Fehlschlag aus und produzierte daher lediglich 3000 Exemplare.
Doch entgegen der Erwartungen kam das Spiel sehr gut an und konnte über...
Moment!
Wir haben ein Game-Kommando, was Black Desert ausspuckt.
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Kassenschlager werden. Das Elder-Scratch-Franchise war geboren.
Etwa zwei Jahre später folgte im Sommer 1996 der zweite Teil, Daggerfall.
Daggerfall, ja, das war verbackt ohne Ende.
Der Titel übertraf seinen Vorgänger sogar noch in Sachen Größe und Komplexität.
Allerdings führte dies dazu, dass das Spiel sehr fehlerbehaftet war und den unschmeichelhaften Beinamen Daggerfall erhielt.
Das war total verbackt.
Später, im Jahr 2001, teilte sich die Firma auf in den Publishing-Bereich, eben Bethesda Softworks, und den Entwicklerbereich, Bethesda Game Studios.
Der Witz ist ja, dass die ganzen Bethesda Games oftmals ziemlich verbackt sind.
Allerdings war es bisher, wobei mittlerweile auch nicht mal früher, immer so, dass da aber ein gutes Spiel unter der Haube steckte.
Und dass vor allem viele Modder dafür gesorgt haben, dass die Spiele noch besser wurden.
Dass ein gutes Spiel unter der Haube steckte.
Da hat man auch ein bisschen drüber weggesehen.
Aber ich meine, Fallout Server 6 ist wachscheiße und inhaltlich scheiße.
Warum sollte man da drüber hinwegsehen?
Warum steht der Typ eigentlich nackt am Feuer?
Ach, ich wusste gar nicht, dass die das, was die auf Fallout 2 gemacht haben.
Von Fallout 3 hatte er ja überhaupt nichts vermittelt.
Fallout 3 war auch nice.
Bethesda war zu dieser Zeit auf einem wahren Höhenflug. Und als sie merkten, dass sie noch mehr Zeit brauchten, um das Spiel entwickeln zu können, das sie sich erhofften, gaben sie die Lizenz an ein vielversprechendes Studio ab.
Das Resultat war der grandiose Ableger Fallout New Vegas, der bis heute für viele als das beste Spiel der Fallout Reihe gilt.
Dasselbe hätten sie gerne auch mit der Elder Scrolls Lizenz probieren dürfen, aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Man kann im Laufe einer Entwicklung nur selten genau bestimmen, was der konkrete Moment der Veränderung war.
Und kein erprobtes Ereignis, das einen Kurswechsel aufzeigt. Im Falle von Bethesda würde ich sagen, ungefähr zur Releasezeit von Fallout 4 begann die Talfahrt.
Zuvor erschienen die beiden hervorragenden DLCs Dawn Guard und Dragonborn für Skyrim, beide übrigens im selben Jahr 2012. Und bis zum Release von Fallout 4 in 2015 veröffentlichte Bethesda kein weiteres Spiel.
Also muss der Wandel irgendwo in diesem Zeitraum begonnen haben. Fallout 4 selbst war kein totales Desaster. Viele Spieler waren zufrieden mit dem Spiel.
Bei Fallout 4 hast du schon gemerkt, dass qualitativ schon einige Kompromisse eingegangen wurden und nicht mehr alles so rosig war.
Bis heute ist es sogar das zweitmeist gemoddete Spiel auf Nexus Mods. Nur Vanilla Skyrim hat noch mehr Mods zur Auswahl.
Fallout 4 war nicht der kritische Erfolg, den viele erwartet hatten. Die Story wirkte etwas deplatziert in einem so großen Open-World-Spiel und neu erdachte Systeme wie die Settlements konnten nicht gänzlich überzeugen.
Dennoch herrschte allgemein der Konsens, dass es ein gutes Fallout-Spiel ist und die Verkaufszahlen weisen es sogar als den erfolgreichsten Teil der Reihe aus.
Jetzt haben viele Leute halt gekauft. Das spricht nicht unbedingt. Also reine Verkaufszahlen, vor allem bei Serienspielen, sagt nicht unbedingt was darüber aus, ob das der beste Serienteil ist.
Gerade weil neue Serien, also Spiele aus der Serie halt sehr von dem guten Ruf der vorangegangenen Teile profitieren, sodass die Leute die ganze Sache einfach... Ja, guckt euch das letzte Pokémon-Game an, genau.
Jemandem den metaphorischen Spiegel vorzuhalten ist nie eine schöne Angelegenheit. Dennoch ist es in vielen Fällen sinnvoll, Fehler aufzuzeigen, damit sie in Zukunft vermieden werden.
Die letzten Jahre waren einfach nicht gut von Bethesda. Die beiden Virtual-Reality-Versionen von Skyrim und Fallout sollen noch ganz in Ordnung gewesen sein, aber davon abgesehen...
War vorerst Skyrim, die so viele Leute immer halt kotzen mussten?
Immerhin bewies Bethesda hier eine gute Portion Selbstironie, da sie selbst ein Video herausgebracht haben, das die Very Special Edition vorgestellt hat.
Das war lustig, das war doch genau, das war, wo sie Alexa Skyrim gespielt haben.
Die zweite Skyrim Neuerung war dagegen leider kein Witz. Für den Creation Club hagelte es seit seiner Ankündigung Kritik.
Oh, das war dieser Modding-Service. Ja.
Voll der Witz! Ich meine, das Spiel ist 10 Jahre vorher rausgekommen oder so in dem Dreh. Die Mods gibt es kostenlos und auf einmal sollen die Leute dafür was bezahlen.
Vor allem die Modder, das ist ja nicht so, als wollten die auf einmal, als wollten die damit irgendwie reich werden oder so.
Das war einfach nur, dass Bethesda Geld abgreifen konnte.
Was hältst du vom Pokémon Schwert und Schild DLC, dass rauskommt? Kein Schimmer.
Ich hab das Game noch nicht mal.
Der Gedanke dahinter ist...
Ja, Eax, ist schon ein bisschen müde.
... für die Entwicklung bezahlt werden und somit hochwertigen Content produzieren, doch leider sah die Realität anders aus.
Entgegen der offiziellen Ankündigung bestand der Inhalt des Clubs vor allem aus Waffenskins aus früheren Spielen und dem ein oder anderen Haus.
Dafür wurden aber hohe Summen verleiht.
Alter, 10 Jahre nach Skyrim oder 8 Jahre nach Skyrim Release erst mal Skyrim Waffenskins rausbringen, das ist so fail!
... 5€ für ein Schwert. Und man konnte es auch nicht direkt kaufen, sondern musste die Zwischenwährung Credits verwenden.
Dass zudem auch nur sehr spärlich neue Inhalte erscheinen, half der Willy-Pet auch nicht gerade.
Wobei man der Fairness-Hyber sagen muss, dass in den letzten beiden Updates durchaus ordentlich Inhalte dabei waren.
Im Bereich der Mobile-Games haben sie nach dem enormen Erfolg von Fallout Shelter ein weiteres Spiel veröffentlicht.
Viola Scrooge's Blades.
Es sollte ein vollwertiges RPG für Mobiltelefone werden, doch die Meinungen gingen dabei weit auseinander.
Das Spiel hat sicherlich seine positiven Aspekte.
Für ein Mobile-Game sah das wirklich gut aus. Ich kann mich noch an die Ankündigungen erinnern, wo ich mir gedacht habe, hey, mal gucken, ob sie das gut umsetzen.
Beispielsweise die wirklich gute Grafik für Handys, die Klickentwicklung oder auch das Kampfsystem für ein Mobile-Game.
Aber die wurden leider von vielen negativen Aspekten überschattet.
Viele kritisierten die langen Ladezeiten, die Menge an Grinding, die notwendig war und vor allem die Mikrotransaktionen, die das Spiel verseucht haben.
Was sonst? Hat jemand wirklich mit was anderem gerechnet?
Ich weiß noch, wo sie erzählt haben, so irgendwie ein vollständiges neues Elder Scrolls Experience, bla, auf dem Smartphone.
Es war eigentlich schon jedem, der darüber mal ein bisschen länger nachgedacht hat.
Klar, das Game mag zwar im Kern vielleicht nicht schlecht sein, aber es wird versaut durch halt Mobile-Gaming.
Zu Beginn hatte man stark das Gefühl, Geld zahlen zu müssen, um in dem Spiel verresst zu kommen.
Das ist eigentlich eine Big-Prain-Idee für ein Hintergrundvideo.
Ich gehe einfach in irgendein MMO, laufe mit meinem Charakter rum, dann habe ich schönes Hintergrund-Gameplay für irgendein Video, wo ich dann eine halbe Stunde was erzählen kann.
Trotz der teils harschen Kritik war Blights ein finanzieller Erfolg.
Innerhalb der ersten Woche konnten schon mehr als eine Million Downloads verzeichnet werden und im ersten Monat wurden bereits mehr als 1,5 Millionen Dollar eingenommen.
Am schlimmsten war allerdings der Release von Fallout 76.
Ohje, ja gut, das hatten wir ja schon in einem eigenen Video.
Und GameSpot, a soulless husk of an experience.
Um nur mal ein paar zu nennen.
Andere Outlets, wie beispielsweise Giant Bomb, hatten nicht mal ein Review veröffentlicht, was sich niemand in deren Team bereit erklärt hat, das Spiel zu testen.
Es wollte einfach niemand das Spiel.
Die Versuche von Bethesda, das Spiel...
Will jemand das neue Skype, das neue, nein, geht mir weg.
... noch mehr Fehlern und dementsprechend noch mehr Frust bei den Spiels.
Alleine der erste Patch war mit 50 Gigabyte ungefähr genau so groß wie das Spiel selbst.
Aber auch rund um das Spiel zeigte sich Bethesda von der schlechtesten Seite.
Käufe der extra teuren Power Armor Edition bekamen nicht die Tasche von den...
Ja, das kennen wir ja schon.
Das kennen wir schon.
Die Cola.
Ach, Darkrum, Grum, nicht Cola.
Eine billige...
Richtig billiges Plastikding.
Genau.
Und da gab es noch dieses Video zu, dass man das noch nicht mal verwenden kann.
Hier.
Wartet mal.
Wenn er jetzt versucht aus der Flasche rauszuschütten.
Pass mal auf.
Du lepperst.
Guck mal.
Du kannst es nicht mal rausschütten aus der Flasche.
Richtig.
Das ist doch kaputt.
So dermaßen schief, dass Nutzer die Support-Tickets an der Flasche schütten.
So dermaßen schief, dass Nutzer die Support-Tickets anderer Nutzer einsehen konnten.
Inklusive persönlicher Daten wie Name, Adresse und sogar Kreditkarteinformationen.
Das haben die Leute schon wieder vergessen.
Eine Sache, die mich ja bei diesen ganzen Fails der Spielehersteller, nicht nur Spielehersteller.
Es ist eigentlich unabhängig von Spielehersteller.
Auch irgendwelche Elektronikhersteller, die in der Datenbank liegen, habt ihr das hier mitgekriegt.
Der Hersteller, wo ich meine Kameras von gekauft habe, hat eine Datenbank live auf einem China-Server im Internet stehen gehabt.
2,5 Millionen User-Data.
Allerdings, ich habe meine Kameras ja geflasht und in einem eigenen Netz.
Also ich hatte nicht das Problem.
Dazu war es möglich, dass theoretisch jeder auf der Welt die Videostreams abgreifen konnte.
Von den Kameras, weil die Kameras ja nicht nur Car gestreamt haben, sondern über die China-Cloud gestreamt haben.
Und eins muss man sagen, die Leute vergessen solche Sachen viel zu schnell.
Es dauert keinen Monat.
Also erstens lassen die Leute das den Herstellern viel zu easy durchgehen.
Und die Leute vergessen das auch ultra schnell.
Es ist sogar mittlerweile so lächerlich, auf dem Reddit, auf dem Sub-Reddit für diesen Hersteller,
wird der Hersteller dafür gefeiert, dass sie jetzt Two-Factor-Authentifizierung machen wollen nach dem Leak.
So nach dem Motto, die reagieren aber schnell auf diese Sachen.
Nein, die haben es verkackt, die haben es erstmal so krass hardcore verschissen.
Und jetzt werden sie dafür gefeiert, dass sie Two-Factor-Authentifizierung machen wollen.
Wohlgemerkt, sie hatten vorher auch schon teilweise Two-Factor-Authentifizierung, die aber nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Und dazu kommt, es ist nicht so, dass etwa einfach nur Videostreams abgreifbar waren,
sondern auch irgendwie, die hatten auch irgendwie so eine Smart-Wage.
Du konntest alles abgreifen von den Leuten.
Alter, Wohnort, Körperfett, Gewicht, alles in der China-Datbank, Alter.
Deswegen die Dinger nicht in der Cloud verwenden.
Mittlerweile ist man auch als Benutzer ja schon so abgehärtet gegen irgendwelche Daten-Leaks und sonst was,
dass es kaum noch einen interessiert.
... lief etwas so dermaßen schief, dass Nutzer die Support-Tickets anderer Nutzer einsehen konnten,
inklusive persönlicher Daten...
Aber die Leute vergessen das so schnell.
... Kreditkarteninformation.
Und trotz all dieser Kritik verkaufte sich das Spiel gut.
Ja gut, weil das ist die Sache, diese Serie hat halt einen super Ruf.
Und man muss auch sagen, guckt euch mal an, wie gut sich die ganze neue Star Wars-Geschichte verkauft.
Ich war noch nie großer Star Wars-Fan, aber der eine Film kam ja auch richtig schlecht bei den Fans an.
Und trotzdem ist das der letzte Film, einer der erfolgreichsten Filme ever.
Also Fans sind da recht resistent, muss man sagen.
Das Spiel erschien am 14. November 2018 und verkaufte noch im selben Jahr ca. 1,4 Millionen Einheiten.
Und von den Abo-Gebühren für Privatserver möchte ich hier gar nicht erst anfangen.
Als einziger Lichtblick in den letzten Jahren kann man wohl The Elder Scrolls online nennen.
Der MMO-Ableger wird allerdings gar nicht von Bethesda Game Studios entwickelt,
sondern lediglich von Bethesda Softworks gepublished.
Elder Scrolls Online soll tatsächlich nicht schlecht geworden sein.
Und im nächsten Jahr auch schon die vierte Erweiterung am Skyrim miterhalten wird,
wollte ich das zumindest mal erwähnt haben.
Oh, habe ich jetzt mal ein Feuerwerkeffekt gemacht.
Zumindest wurde die Entwicklung eingestellt.
Sie sind einfach nicht das Kerngeschäft von Bethesda.
Sie sind bekannt geworden durch ihre grandiosen Singleplayer-RPGs.
Und hier müssen sie in Zukunft liefern.
Bethesda hat sich schon viel zu lange auf den Lorbeeren von Skyrim ausgeruht.
Die Konkurrenz schläft nicht und im Laufe der letzten Jahre hat sie Bethesda den Rang abgelaufen.
Wenn ich heutzutage an große Spieleentwickler im RPG-Bereich denke, fällt nicht der Name Bethesda.
Ich meine, um noch was zu dieser ganzen Star Wars Geschichte zu sagen,
nichtsdestotrotz, dass es viele Fans enttäuscht waren.
Aber viele sind da auch richtig fanatisch.
Ich habe letztens einen Artikel darüber gelesen, dass die weibliche Hauptdarstellerin
und der männliche Hauptdarsteller, dass sie Drohungen bekommen,
weil sie in real life sich nicht daten.
Beziehungsweise weil sie jemand anderes daten oder mit jemand anderem zusammen sind.
Das viele Fans im Kopf irgendwie dann nicht verarbeiten können,
dass quasi die Filmcharaktere nicht in echt dann auch weiter...
Ey, da denke ich mir auch immer, Leute, ihr seid so unglaublich...
Fanboys, Alter, Fanboys waren schon immer dämlich.
So richtig, richtig...
Das tut mir echt...
Das tut weh.
Ich meine Fanboys nicht. Ich habe keine Fanboys.
Ich habe nur Cute Chat.
Es fallen Namen wie CD Projekt RED oder die Santa Monica Studios.
Seit dem letzten Singleplayer-RPG von Bethesda sind nun schon vier Jahre vergangen,
weil ein neues ist derzeit nicht in sich.
Es werden nur ab und an vage Aussagen veröffentlicht,
dass man an 3 großen aber geheimen Werken arbeite, worum es sich dabei handelt und wann sie erscheinen sollen, ist aber unbekannt.
Wir wissen lediglich, dass sie an Elder Scrolls 6 arbeiten, aber ob es in 1, 2 oder 10 Jahren erscheint, wer weiß.
Nicht einmal der Name des Spiels ist schon offiziell bekannt gegeben worden.
Ebenso wenig das Gebiet, in dem es spielen soll.
Spieler werden nur vertröste mit Hinweisen auf Technologien, die erst noch entwickelt werden müssen,
um die Vision des Spiels realisieren zu können.
Das sind Aussagen, die mittlerweile mehr wie Ausreden klingen.
Vor ein paar Jahren hätte ich sie vielleicht noch geglaubt,
aber später sind seit den Debakeln der letzten Jahre nicht mehr.
Es ist mir völlig schleierhaft, wie man eine so erfolgreiche Spielereihe nicht weiterführen kann.
Es ist ja nicht so wie einem FIFA oder früher Assassin's Creed jedes Jahr einen neuen Titel herausbringen.
Da wusste man nicht. Guckt euch die Werfe an, Half-Life 3.
8 Jahre Wartezeit und immer noch kein neuer Titel in Sicht? Wie kann das sein?
Alleine aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht kann ich einfach nicht nachvollziehen, dass kein weiteres Spiel erschienen ist.
Selbst wenn sie keine eigenen Kapazitäten für ein neues Spiel haben sollten,
was ich nicht glaube bei den Einnahmen,
dann hätte man die Lizenz doch einfach eine andere Studio für ein Spin-Off oder ein Skyrim 2 geben können.
Mit Fallout New Vegas hatten sie doch sogar gute Erfahrungen in dem Bereich gemacht.
Wieso also nicht auch mit der Elder Scrolls Reihe?
Daher liegt das besondere Augenmerk auf dem nächsten großen RPG der Bethesda Game Studios, Starfield.
Hab ich noch nie was von gehört. Jeder was von gehört? Starfield sagt mir gar nichts.
Es wird ein Rollenspiel sein und es wird im Weltraum spielen.
Es wird zudem die erste neue IP von Bethesda seit 25 Jahren sein.
Aber auch hier hört man seit dem kurzen Teaser auf der E3 2018 nichts mehr.
Nach den viel trittenen und mittelmäßigen Spielen der letzten Jahre ist Starfield ein echter Gradmesser für die Zukunft von Bethesda geworden.
Sie vergraulen nach und nach ihre ansonsten äußerst loyale Spielschaft.
Alleine das Skyrim 8 Jahre nach Release immer noch in der florierenden Mod-Szene hat, ist schon beeindruckend.
Aber jetzt brauchen sie mal wieder einen richtigen Erfolg.
Der Kredit ist einfach aufgebaut.
Das stimmt, kenne ich ihm recht.
Aber er hat recht leider, das Problem ist, dass die Spieler die ganzen Sachen oder generell alle Leute immer das so schnell vergessen.
Deswegen im Prinzip können Hersteller fast machen, was sie wollen.
Das ist das Gleiche, wie im Endeffekt YouTuber machen können, was sie wollen.
Solange sie weiterhin Inhalte machen, die den Inhalten entsprechen, weshalb die Leute halt da hingehen.
Also sprich, wenn einer jetzt Funny Prank Videos macht und er baut mal mit irgendwas richtig scheiße und alle regen sich auf.
Zwei Wochen redet wieder keiner mehr drüber.
Hauptsache er macht weiterhin Funny Prank Videos, weil das die Leute ist, das ist was die Leute sehen wollen.
Die Leute interessiert eigentlich überhaupt nicht, ob der irgendwie scheiße baut.
Das ist eigentlich vollkommen egal.
Hauptsache er macht weiter Funny Prank Videos.
So, jetzt gucken wir als nächstes.
Diese Ego Shooter auf Game Style.
Komm, wir müssen uns noch mal gucken von wem das ist.
Mal gucken, ob wir uns das geben können.
Von wem ist das Video?
2020 könnte ein richtig gutes Jahr für Shooter werden.
Ah, der ist gut. Den kann man sich geben.
Und das nicht nur im Big Budget Bereich.
Abseits ganz großer Marken erscheinen über das Jahr einige vielversprechende Shooter, die ganz bestimmte Fan-Nischen ansprechen.
Beispielsweise Oldschool-Fans, Taktik-Freunde oder VR-Enthusiast.
Deswegen stürzen wir uns direkt in die Materie.
Hier sind alle vielversprechenden Shooter, die für 2020 entweder offiziell bestätigt oder zumindest sehr wahrscheinlich sind.
Oh Gott, Overwatch 2. Hör mal auf, Overwatch Season 2.
Retro-Shooter sind gerade voll im Trend.
Prodeus ist, was Doom Eternal wäre, wenn es den Retro-Look von damals beibehalten hätte.
Ein extrem schneller, blutiger Oldschool-Shooter,
in dem ihr mit Schrotflinte gegen Aliens kämpft, Secrets in den umfangreichen Leveln findet und euch ganz...
Das Einzige, was an der Grafik Oldschool ist, ist aber auch nur die Auflöser, oder?
Weil sowohl von Spiegelung und sonst was her sieht das nicht Oldschool aus.
Ein konkretes Release-Datum gibt es noch nicht.
Irgendwann 2020 soll es soweit sein für PC, PS4, Switch und Xbox One.
Und um gleich im selben Themenfeld zu bleiben, nach einer Verschiebung erscheinte Doom Eternal, der Nachfolger des 2016...
Stimmt, sollte das nicht jetzt rauskommen?
... am 20. März 2020 für PC, Switch, PS4 und Xbox One.
Auch hier bleiben die Entwickler ihren Wurzeln treu.
In opulenter Grafik wird geballert, zersägt und verprügelt, bis kein Dämon sich mehr aus der Hölle wagt.
Diesmal übrigens auch auf der Erde.
Neu ist ein Fokus auf Platforming-Passagen und natürlich wird sich auch an Gegner- und Ballervielfalt einiges erweitern.
Alter, jetzt übertreibt man nicht mit der Musik.
Im März 2020 erscheint doch tatsächlich ein neues...
Da freue ich mich drauf!
Das ist das Spiel, wo ich mich am Abstand am meisten darauf freue bzw. darauf gespannt bin dieses Jahr.
Und vielleicht hole ich mir dafür auch einen VR-Headset.
... sondern einen VR-Ableger Half-Life Alex spielt zwischen Half-Life 1 und 2.
Er soll angeblich 15 Stunden Kampagne haben.
Er schafft gegen die diktatorischen Combine und für das Überleben der Menschheit.
Und gleich noch mal Half-Life.
Seit über einem Jahrzehnt wird an Black Mesa gearbeitet.
Ja, das haben wir schon gespielt.
Das haben wir ja schon.
Ursprünglich erzeugt und konzipiert ist das Ding mittlerweile ein eigenständiges Spiel, auch wenn sich die Grundideen nie geändert hat.
Black Mesa versteht sich als Remake von Half-Life 1 in der Source-Engine von Half-Life 2.
In der Early Access-Version könnt ihr Black Mesa jetzt bereits spielen.
Im Frühjahr 2020 soll auch das letzte Gebiet, der Alien-Planet Xen, die Beta verlassen und die Vollversion damit fertig sein.
Zugegeben, in Dying Light 2 wird gar nicht so viel geballert, weil ich in dieser Zombie-Post-Apokalypse eher mit Knüppeln, Echsen und Klingen kämpfe.
Gibt eh schon zu viele Zombie-Games.
Oder dank der coolen Parkour-Fähigkeiten auf den Dächern rumhopse.
Trotzdem leben in diesem Open-World-Epos viele Shootertugenden.
Das besondere Schmanker wird aber die offene Spielwelt, die sich je nach Entscheidungen in der Story drastisch verändern soll.
Und Open-World brauch ich nicht.
Auch Chernobyl Light ist kein klassischer Shooter wie Doom, auch wenn es jede Menge Knarren, Ego-Perspektive und ziemlich...
Chernobyl Light oder was?
Das kleine Chernobyl.
Aber tatsächlich geht es mehr um das Überleben an einem der tödlichsten Orte der Welt, der verstrahlten Zone von Chernobyl.
Um eure Freundin zu retten, reist ihr in die Vergangenheit zum Zeitpunkt des Chernobyl-Unglücks und entdeckt die Mysterien dieser verstrahlten Welt.
Story-Entscheidungen, cleveres Item-Management und strategisches Vorgehen stehen im Zentrum von Chernobyl Light.
Wer damals Stalker mochte, dürfte 2020 auf PC, Xbox One und PS4 also Grund zur Freude haben.
Ein konkretes Release-Datum gibt es allerdings noch nicht.
Ready or Not bedient eine Nische, die lange kein Shooter mehr zufriedenstellend ausfüllen konnte.
Ein geistiger Erbe der alten SWAT und Rainbow Six Spiele zu sein.
Statt als Pistolero wild rumzuballern zählt in diesem Taktik-Shooter strategisches Vorgehen.
Wer Gegner mit einem gut geplanten Zugriff überrascht, Blendgranaten durch die Tür wirft und sich mit seinen Kollegen abspricht,
muss teils nicht mal eine Kugel abfeuern.
Ready or Not enthält Solo- und Co-op-Kampagne sowie einen PvP-Multiplayer.
Das Spiel erscheint im vierten Quartal 2020 für PC, vorher steht eine Beta an.
Wer die 110 Euro teure Supporter-Edition kauft, kann jetzt bereits in die Alpha reinschnuppern.
Aber das ist auch ein ordentlicher Batzen Geld.
Wer hätte das gedacht, 2020 erscheint tatsächlich ein Nachfolger von Overwatch auf PS4, Xbox One und PC.
Es ist halt einfach, ich weiß, da sagt es, weil Blizzard es selber so verkauft, ist das auch klar,
das ist einfach kein richtiger Nachfolger, das ist ein bisschen Kampagne gescriptet und im Endeffekt Service Pack 1.
Overwatch 2 versteht sich als eine Art Kombipaket.
Alle PvP-Komponenten, also Modi, Karten, Helden erscheinen...
Wenn es danach spielt, wie alt ist Reinhardt eigentlich jetzt, 108 oder wie?
...wohl in Teil 1 als auch in Teil 2, sind also quasi kombiniert ein einziges Produkt.
Für Overwatch 2 exklusiv ist lediglich der neue Koop-Modus, in dem ihr gemeinsam gegen...
And they say, and they say, and they say...
So kann's gehen. Ursprünglich war der Zombie-Koop...
Oh, das braucht auch niemand, Alter. Niemand, niemand.
Hat, hat, hat in Rainbow Six irgendjemand nach einem Zombie-Survival-Ding gefragt?
Irgendjemand?
2020 wird daraus aber ein eigenes Spiel.
In Rainbow Six Quarantine tretet ihr gemeinsam mit zwei Freunden gegen Horden von Infizierten an,
die sich wie ein guter Halbmehl für den unterschiedlichen Gegnertypen aufspalten.
Manche halten extrem viel aus, andere sind extrem schnell.
Wenn es was taugt, warum nicht? Ich glaub nicht, dass es was taugt.
Warten wir mal ab, was Quarantine noch um drauf packt.
Neben FIFA ist Call of Duty eine der wenigen Serien, die immer noch jedes Jahr erscheint.
Auch 2020 rechnen wir mit einem neuen Call of Duty, und Insidern zufolge hat das bereits einen Namen.
Treyarch werkelt angeblich an Black Ops 5.
Ob sich das in Black Ops 4 wieder ganz auf Multiplayer konzentriert
oder wie Modern Warfans Singleplayer-Kampagne einbaut, wissen wir noch nicht.
Aber Activision wird es sich sicherlich nicht nehmen lassen, im Herbstgeschäft 2020
den Auftakt von PS5 und Xbox Series X mit einem Next-Gen-Cod zu zelebrieren.
Viel wissen wir noch nicht über das neue Halo, aber die paar Infos machen zumindest neugierig.
Halo Infinite setzt die Story des Vorgängers fort, versteht sich jedoch als eine Art Soft Reboot.
Der Master Chief soll anders als in Teil 5 wieder stärker im Vordergrund stehen
und ganz generell sollen die Stärken von früher...
Was zum Teufel soll ein Soft Reboot sein?
... wieder glänzen können.
Ohne Zweifel soll...
Es spielt danach, aber ist im Geiste wie Teil 1 oder wie, oder was?
... 2003 satte 34 Level, in denen ihr euch durch eine spannende Agentengeschichte quer über den Globus schießt.
Ach, das war das!
Atomic Heart sollte euch dabei nicht abschrecken, denn unter der Haube ist XIII ein wirklich herausragender Shooter,
der ab und zu auch Schleichen und alternative Siege erlaubt.
Die Story erinnert dabei stark an den ersten Jason Bourne-Film.
2020 bekommt der Klassiker eine Neuauflage, die die Stärken von einst auf alle aktuellen Konsolen bringen soll.
Atomic Heart lässt sich ganz gut als Soviet Bioshock bezeichnen.
In einer alternativen Historie landet ihr in einer Sowjetunion mit retro-futuristischem Einschlag...
Es sieht tatsächlich ein bisschen nach BioShock aus.
... und andere Gefahren bestehen, euch Waffen craften und so weiter.
Ursprünglich sollte das Spiel schon 2019 rauskommen.
Ein konkretes Release-Datum für 2020 gibt es jetzt immer noch nicht,
aber immerhin wissen wir, dass Atomic Heart für PC, PS4 und Xbox One erscheint.
Die Serious Sam Serie ist genau wie ihr Titel hält, ein Dimensional, aber launig.
Damals ballerten wir Wunderschaffen von Aliens über den Haufen.
2020 tun wir das wieder in Serious Sam 4 Planet Badass.
Die Level sollen deutlich größer ausfallen als im Original,
allerdings betonen die Entwickler explizit, dass Serious Sam 4 kein Open-World-Spiel wird.
Das lineare Feeling der Klassiker soll ausfallen.
Es ist halt das Gefühl, es macht jeder Open-World, um Open-World zu machen,
nicht um sinnvoll, das zu integrieren.
Genau, Choi!
Waaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa!
Hehe!
...rechterhalten werden, nur eben modernisiert für ein aktuelles Publikum.
Ein Release-Datum steht noch aus,
wir rächen aber für 2020 fest mit einer PC-Veröffentlichung.
Hellbound ist ein weiterer PC-Retro-Shooter und bleibt in vielen Punkten sehr nah an Doom.
Auch hier kämpft ihr gegen Dämonen-Horden, umgeben von feuriger Lava.
Anders als beim 2016er Doom ist auch der Look trotz 3D-Technik nah an damals ebenso das Movement.
Wer 2020 also wie damals mit Shotty und Nahkampfwaffe auf die Jagd gehen möchte, muss nicht zwangsläufig auf Doom Eternal setzen.
Anders als bei Doom Eternal gibt es hier allerdings noch kein exaktes Release-Datum.
Ihr könnt allerdings in der Early Access-Version schon einen Survival-Modus spielen.
Und wieder Retro. Wrath, Aion of Ruin ist nicht nur schwierig auszusprechen, sondern es bleibt ebenfalls nahe an Klassikern wie Hexen, Doom und Co.
Es versetzt euch in ein Gruselszenario mit allerlei Horror-Gepieles und gibt euch wunderbar wuchtige Knarren an die Hand.
Die doppeläufige Schrotflinte ist hier bloß ein Highlight.
Eher wie Quake 2. Das sieht eher aus wie Quake 2. Ich will mich bei diesen Retro-Shooter nicht die ganze Zeit wiederholen,
weil ihr ja seht, was Wrath, Aion of Ruin ausmacht und all die anderen auch.
Eine Besonderheit gibt es allerdings, das Spiel ist jetzt bereits im Early Access verfügbar.
Die Vollversion für alle Konsolen kommt im Sommer 2020.
Die Sniper-Serie nahm schon immer noch einen besonderen Platz innerhalb der Shooter-Landschaft ein.
Für viele Gelegenheitszucker mussten...
Da hab ich mal Sellout gemacht auf YouTube. Vor drei Jahren oder so.
...viel zu langsam vorgehen. Enthusiasten entdecken aber genau hier in den Reiz der Sniper-Serie.
2019 wurden Sniper Elite 5 und Sniper Elite VR angekündigt.
Wirklich handfeste Infos gibt es zwar noch nicht...
Sniper Elite VR!
...auch wieder eine Open World bekommt, aber mit ein bisschen Glück erfahren wir bald mehr.
Ist ja fast wie echt.
Mit ein bisschen mehr Glück erscheint zumindest eines der beiden Spiele noch 2020.
Bright Memory ist ein bisschen kompliziert.
Eine Early Access Version einer ersten Episode ist bereits erschienen und war eine ziemliche Leuchtfacke.
Kurz, hell und wunderschön.
Mit einem beeindruckenden Mix aus Ballereien, rasante Movements, spektakulären Effekten und brachialem Nahkampf.
Das chinesische Spiel wurde von nur einer Person entwickelt.
Die Weiterentwicklung dieser ersten Episode wurde dann aber eingeschränkt, weil der Entwickler von der positiven Resonanz und den Verkaufszahlen so positiv überrascht wurde,
dass er jetzt ein größeres Gesamtspiel machen möchte.
Bright Memory Infinite.
In einer futuristischen Großstadt des Jahres 2036 kämpft ihr als Spezial-Agentin gegenüber natürliche Phänomene.
2020 soll Infinite auf PC in den Startlöchern stehen.
Indie-Entwickler The Astronauts mag vielen von euch vielleicht kein Name sein, doch eine Sache kann das Team unfassbar gut aussehende Spiele machen.
Schon 2014 gelang das mit The Vanishing of Ethan Carter, damals noch als reinrassiges Adventure, das mit Fotogrammetrie echte Fotoaufnahmen in virtuelle Umgebungen verwandelte.
Witchfire enthält deutlich mehr Action als Vanishing of Ethan Carter.
Hier wird geschossen, gegruselt und bestaunt, denn bereits in den ersten Trailern sehen die Umgebungen einfach nur gut aus.
Wann wir uns in die Dark-Fantasy-Welt stürzen können, steht derzeit noch nicht fest, irgendwann 2020 soll es erstmal nur auf dem PC dann soweit sein.
Disintegration gehört definitiv zu den originellsten Shootern in dieser Liste.
Und das nicht nur, weil das Spiel von Marcus Leto, also einem der Urväter hinter Halo und Destiny, entwickelt wird.
Nein, der Shooter mixt seine Ballereien ausgerechnet mit strategischem RTS-Gameplay.
Ihr befähigt nicht nur den Piloten eines Schwebegleiters in einem Science-Fiction-Krieg, sondern auch Truppen auf dem Boden.
Klingt jetzt irgendwie nach ein bisschen merkwürdiger Mischung.
Könnte aber wie in einem Taktik-Shooter Kommandos verteilen.
Die Story soll eine große Rolle spielen, neben dem PvP-Multiplayer gibt es auch eine Kampagne.
Ich freue mich aber vor allem auf die kreativen Zerstörungs-Sandboxes, die durch dieses Strategiezeugs entstehen dürften.
Disintegration erscheint irgendwann 2020 für PC, PS4 und Xbox One.
Auch Fans von Horror-Shootern können 2020 auf dem PC Grund zum Grusel bekommen.
Scorn beeindruckte in bisher gezeigten Szenen vor allem durch seine groteske Optik.
Die Monster und Umgebungs-Designs wurden unter anderem von H.R. Giger inspiriert, dem Schöpfer des weltberühmten Ridley Scott Alien.
Auch in Scorn beginnen wir uns in furchterregend fremde Umgebungen und steuern ein menschenähnliches Wesen ohne Haut.
Die Entwickler wollen dieses Gefühl von ins Unbekannte geworfen erzeugen.
Bisher ranken sich rund um Scorn also vor allem Fragen.
Wie wichtig wird das Schießen im Spiel? Worum geht es in der Geschichte wirklich?
Und kommt es denn nun 2020, denn offiziell steht ein Release-Datum noch aus?
Weltkriegsshooter gab es über die Jahre ja so einige und auch Battlefield 5 kämpft 2020 nach wie vor um die Beliebtheit bei den Fans.
Doch die Konkurrenz schläft nicht. Enlisted ist ein Online-Multiplayer-Schütze...
Ja leider hat die Konkurrenz bisher immer ziemlich gesackt.
Und das Problem war, dass Battlefield auch immer schle... also zumindest.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man sagen kann, immer schlechter geworden ist, aber nicht so in die Richtung, wie es mir gefallen hat.
Ähm... Ich hoffe mal, ich spekuliere ja irgendwie noch drauf, sie schaffen es.
Oder sie hoffens, ich hoffe, dass sie es schaffen.
So rum, dass das keine leere Vermutung bleibt, dass Bad Company 3 irgendwann mal rauskommt.
WF5 jetzt muss mal anschauen. Ich habe gehört, dass Battlefield 5 jetzt mit diesem Pacific DLC ganz okay geworden sein muss.
... mit den Machern von War Thunder entwickelt wird.
Das Spiel will euch nicht einfach in Baller-Arenen werfen, sondern bemüht sich um ein echtes Schlachtgefühl.
Realismus, taktisches Vorgehen, Teamarbeit sind wichtiger als ein hoher Kill Count.
Gerade weil jede Kugel tödlich ist und die Teamgrößen sehr üppig ausfallen.
Die Entwickler betonen, dass sie erreichen wollen, was den meisten zweiter Weltkriegsspiele misslinkt.
Dass sich beide Teams wirklich um die strategischen Ziele des jeweils abgebildeten Konflikts bemühen, statt einfach nur Feinde abzuknallen.
Ja, aber Kills machen ist das Beste in Games.
... erscheint ist allerdings noch nicht in trockenen Tüchern. In den letzten Monaten ist es bedenklich still um das Projekt geworden, warten wir also mal ab.
Erstmal Quickscope, so wie sie das in echt auch gemacht haben.
In Journey to the Savage Planet bereist ihr als Astronaut einen bisher unerkundeten Planeten und guckt, was dort so geht.
Anders als etwa in Scorn erwarten euch keine mordlösteren Kreaturen aus Clive Barker-Albträumen, sondern kuriose Küken und allerlei knalliges Getiers.
Journey to the Savage Planet soll laut der kanadischen Entwickler ein optimistisches, unterhaltsames Spiel werden, das euch für einige Stunden in eine fremde Welt entführt.
Release ist der 28.1.2020 für PC, PS4 und Xbox One.
Earthbreakers lässt Fans des uralten Command & Conquer Renegade 2020 zumindest auf den PC...
Renegade ist ja schon uralt!